GOOD MORNING THE SENATE
COMMITTEE ON GOVERNMENTAL
ORGANIZATION WILL COME TO ORDER.
IN RESPONSE THE COVERT NINETEEN
EMERGENCY AND TO PROTECT THE
PUBLIC LEGISLATORS AND
EMPLOYEES WE MUST LIMIT
NONESSENTIAL GATHERINGS AND IF
YOU'RE A SOCIAL DISTANCING THE
FACE COVERING. GUIDELINES IN
PLACE FOR THOSE ORDERS SAID
ISN'T MADE NECESSARY
ADJUSTMENTS TO NORMAL PRACTICES
IN ORDER TO PUSH INSURE THE-
PUBLIC CONTINUES TO HAVE ACCESS
TO THE LEGISLATIVE PROCESS. TO
ALLOW PUBLIC ACESS WE'VE
ADMITTED MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
TO TWO HEARING ROOMS NEXT AT
THAT SOCIAL DISTINCT THING
REQUIREMENTS ALLOW. IT WILL BE
USING A TELECONFERENCE SERVICE
FOR THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH
TO TESTIFY TODAY. FOR ALL
INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT THE PARTICIPANT
TOLL FREE NUMBER AND ACCESS
CODE IS POSTED ON OUR COMMITTEE
WEBSITE. IT WILL BE DISPLAYED
ON THE SCREEN INTEL ANNOUNCE IT
NOW. TODAY'S PARTICIPANT NUMBER
IS. EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN THREE
THREE SIX FOUR FOUR THREE
SEVEN. AND THE ACCESS CODE IS.
EIGHT TWO SIX EIGHT FOUR TWO
EIGHT FOR DETAILED INSTRUCTIONS
ON HOW THE TELECONFERENCES THAT
WORKS. PLEASE REFER TO THE
SENATE INDOOR COMMITTEE WEBSITE.
WHEN WE MOVED TO PUBLIC COMMENT
YOU'LL BE PROMPTED BY A
MODERATOR TO DIAL ONE THAT ZERO
FOR SUPPORT IN OPPOSITION.
PRESS THIS IS ONLY ONE TIME AND
WAIT PATIENTLY FOR AN OPERATOR
TO ASSIGN YOU TO A LINE NUMBER
THIS CAN BE A SHORT WAIT WHAT
YOU RECEIVE YOUR LINE NUMBER
YOU WILL WAIT IN QUEUE FOR THE
MODERATOR TO CALL YOUR NUMBER.
AT THAT TIME YOU'LL BE A MUTED
IN YOU'RE READY TO ADDRESS THE
COMMITTEE. PLEASE NOTE THAT IN
ORDER FOR US TO HEAR YOU
CLEARLY AND AVOID ACOUSTIC
FEEDBACK YOU MUST BE YOU THE
DEVICE YOU ARE WATCHING THE
HEARING ON PRIOR TO GIVING
TESTIMONY OVER THE PHONE. IT IS
IMPORTANT WE HEAR FROM YOU AND
WE THANK YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE.
I WILL MAINTAIN DECORUM DURING
THE HEARING AS IS CUSTOMARY IN
ANY INDIVIDUALS DESTRUCTIVE MAY
BE REMOVED FROM THE REMOTE
MEETING OR SERVICE OR HAVE
THEIR CONNECTIONS MUTED. WHILE
EVERY EFFORT HAS BEEN MADE TO
STREAMLINE THE HEARING PROCESS
AND CONDUCT OUR HEARINGS IS
CLOSE TO THE SAME MANNER AS
CUSTOMARY THERE MAY BE SOME
LIKE TIMES FOR PARTICIPANTS WHO
ARE JUST IN THE NEW ONLINE
TOOLS OR TECHNOLOGIES. PLEASE
BE RESPECTFUL PATIENT. SO THAT
ALL. INTERESTED PARTIES CAN BE
HEARD. OKAY TODAY WE HAVE
TWENTY THREE THE BILLS ON THE
AGENDA BEFORE WE HEAR
PRESENTATION ON BILL'S GOING TO
STAB A QUORUM- DO WE HAVE A
QUORUM NOT YET. SO WILL- SO
WE'RE GONNA GET OUT NOW TO MOVE
TO- BOOK. TO SUPPORT THIS WAY A-
SO THIS IS YES SENATOR COM
AUGER. YOU PREPARE TO BEGIN.
YEAH WE'LL START WITH YOUR-
IT'S FILE ITEM NUMBER ONE
EIGHTY ONE ONE EIGHT PLEASE.
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN GOOD
MORNING MEMBERS I AM
PRESENTING. AB ONE EIGHTEEN
WHICH WILL ESTABLISH THE
COMMUNITY RESPONSE INITIATIVE.
TO STRENGTHEN EMERGENCY
SYSTEMS. THE CRISIS ACT PILOT
PROGRAM WILL SUPPORT COMMUNITY
BASED RESPONSES TO LOCAL
EMERGENCY SITUATIONS. EVERY DAY
IN COUNTIES ACROSS THE STATE
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS
ARE SUCCESSFULLY RESPONDING TO
EMERGENCY SITUATIONS SUCH AS
PEOPLE DEALING WITH
HOMELESSNESS PEOPLE
EXPERIENCING A MENTAL HEALTH
CRISIS INTIMATE PARTNER
VIOLENCE COMMUNITY VIOLENCE
PEOPLE EXPERIENCING SUBSTANCE
ABUSE AND IMPACTED BY NATURAL
OR CLIMATE DISASTERS.
UNFORTUNATELY THEIR WORK RELIES
MOSTLY ON DONATIONS. AB ONE
EIGHTEEN IS A REINTRODUCTION OF
AB TWENTY FIFTY FOUR FROM LAST
SESSION. WHICH SUCCESSFULLY GOT
TO THE GOVERNOR'S DESK WITH
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT. AND WE ARE
CONTINUING TO CORRESPOND WITH
THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE ON THIS
MEASURE. SO IN CITIES ACROSS
THE STATE COMMUNITY
ORGANIZATIONS ARE RESPONDING
SUCCESSFULLY TO EMERGENCY
SITUATIONS IN LA ORGANIZATIONS
LIKE SECOND CALL IN MUSTARD
SEED INTERVENE TO BUILD PEACE
DURING NEIGHBORHOOD CONFLICTS
IN THE BAY AREA THE BERKELEY
FREE CLINIC PROVIDED HEALTHCARE
SERVICES TO PEOPLE WHO ARE
UNSHELTERED OR STRUGGLING WITH
SUBSTANCE ABUSE. AND SACRAMENTO
AND OAKLAND MENTAL HEALTH FIRST
MANAGES A HOTLINE FOR RESIDENTS
IN NEED OF IMMEDIATE MENTAL
HEALTH INTERVENTION. AFTER
SUPPORT TEAMS ADDRESSED THE
IMMEDIATE CRISIS THEY WORK TO
STRENGTHEN THE INDIVIDUAL
SUPPORT SYSTEM AND CONNECT THEM
TO RESOURCES. DESPITE THE
POSITIVE IMPACT AND COST
SAVINGS OF COMMUNITY ORIENTED
RESPONSES TO EMERGENCIES
CALIFORNIA HAS DONE LITTLE TO
SUPPORT AND SCALE THESE
EFFORTS. INSTEAD LAW
ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS RESPOND TO
EMERGENCIES BETTER SUITED TO
PEER SUPPORT EXPERTS MENTAL
HEALTH PROVIDERS ARE CRISIS
COUNSELORS TRAINED TO DE
ESCALATE AND RESOLVE CRISES.
THESE KINDS OF SERVICES NEED TO
BE PARTOF THE WEB OF EMERGENCY
RESPONSE NETWORKS. THE CRISIS
ACTORS ABOUT INVESTING IN THE
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS
ACROSS CALIFORNIA. THAT ARE
SUCCESSFULLY RESPONDING TO MANY
TYPES OF SITUATIONS AND HAVE
THE EXPERTISE RELATIONSHIPS
NETWORKS AND TRUST TO BEST MEET
THE NEEDS OF THEIR COMMUNITY.
WITH ME AND SUPPORT AS TONY
SERRANO GARCIA. WAS SILICON
VALLEY DE BUG AND LET YOU SEE A
BEAR AND MOTHER OF MAURICIO
BEREN. THANK YOU IN WHEN THE
TIME IS RIGHT I WILL
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
BOATS. BEFORE THE SPEAKER COMES
ON- CAN WE- MR SECRETARY COULD
WE- LIKE. CALL THE ROLL PLEASE.
STATUS REPORT YES CONTROL DOT
YOUR DAD HERE NELSON NELSON
HERE ALAN ARCHULETA ARCHULETA
HERE BACKER FORGES BRADFORD
LASER- LASER HERE WEST SO.
JONES JONES HERE CAME UNDER
SCANNER HERE MELENDEZ ACCORDING
TO YOU KNOW RUBIO THE OAK
WARRANTY NO HERE. ACCORDING TO
KNOW HERE WILL PRESENT WORK
HERE WE HAVE A CONCERN. OUR
CORE AND IT'S BEEN ESTABLISHED
NOW WILL GO TO THE- WITNESSES-
TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT OF- AB.
ONE ONE EIGHT. WAS IT MISS
GARCIA I DIDN'T. HERE FROM
SILICON VALLEY OR CA YOU MAY
START PLEASE. ARE THE.
MODERATOR DO YOU HAVE THEM ON
THE PUBLIC LINE. I DO NOT. SEE
IT OUT THERE ON THE PHONE.
THEY'RE CALLING THE REGULAR ONE.
OKAY WHILE WE'RE WAITING- FROM
LIZ GARCIA WHAT WE DO IS ASKING
IF THERE'S ANYBODY ON THE LINE-
MODERATOR IN SUPPORT. OF AB.
ONE ONE EIGHT. LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO
SHOW SUPPORT FOR A P. ONE ONE
EIGHT THIS PRESS ONE THEN THERE
ON YOUR PHONE AT THIS TIME. NOT
GO TO THE FIRST LINE NUMBER
FORTY NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS AND IF
THERE'S A COUPLE CHECK WITH
CALIFORNIA FIGHTERS ON BEHALF
OF PUBLIC HEALTH ADVOCATES IN
SUPPORT OF AB ONE EIGHTEEN
THANK YOU SO MUCH. COME FROM
NINE THIRTY THREE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
MALIK BYNUM WITH YOU W. APPS
VEHICLE NINE THIRTY NOT SHOWING
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANKS
THIRTY TO YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
MR CHAIRMAN PARTICULAR KARATE
WITH THE NATURAL RESOURCES
DEFENSE COUNCIL CALLING IN
SUPPORT OF EIGHTY ONE EIGHTEEN
THANK YOU. THANK SEVENTEEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING SURE MEMBERS NOT
YOUR MEMO CALLING IN ON BEHALF
OF JOHN CORPORATION IN SUPPORT.
THANK TWENTY SIX CYLINDER SO
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING SURE MEMBERS MY NAME
IS- CAROUSEL WITH DISABILITY
RIGHTS CALIFORNIA AND STRONG
SUPPORT. ONE FIFTY YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. THE
CALIFORNIA LEAGUE OF
CONSERVATION VOTERS IN SUPPORT.
FIND FIFTY ONE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING SYLVIA POLICE SHOT ON
BEHALF OF THE CITY OF SANTA
MONICA AND THE CITY OF LOS
ANGELES MAYOR ERIC GARCETTI AND
ALSO ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA FACULTY ASSOCIATION
ALL IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
THANKS FIFTY TWO YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. ANDREA
RIVERA ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA PAN ETHNIC HEALTH
NETWORK STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU. FRANK FIFTY THREE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING THIS IS JIM
LINDBERG ON BEHALF OF THE
FRIENDS COMMITTEE ON
LEGISLATION IN CALIFORNIA AND
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANKS THIRTY ACRE LANE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING I
WOULD HAVE DONE WITH ONE GROUP
ON BEHALF OF NEXT IN CALIFORNIA
AND SUPPORT. TWENTY SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MOREAN BRIAN
SCHOBER BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA CLIMATE AND
AGRICULTURE NETWORK IN SUPPORT
OF EIGHTY ONE EIGHTEEN. THANKS
THIRTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING KAREN MEMBERS LUCY
SALCEDO CARTER WITH THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
NONPROFIT SUPPORT. THANKS FORTY
FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING SHARED MEMBERS THIS IS
JENNIFER POTTS AT THE NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER INTO COURT.
THANK TWENTY ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. ONE TWENTY ONE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS-
THIS IS MARCO PARK CALLING ON
BEHALF OF THE CO SPONSORS OF
THE CRISIS BACK- THE ALLIANCE
OF WOMEN OF COLOR. STOP
COALITION ACLU CALIFORNIA
ACTION POLICY LINKED TO A
COMBAT LADY BUG YOU JUSTICE
COALITION A. P. P. P. THE
JUSTICE TEAM CANNOT WORK YOU D.
W. BERKELEY FREE CLINIC OPEN
POWER PROJECTS HE'S BEEN
COMMUNITY LAW CENTRE COURAGE
PUBLIC HEALTH ADVOCATES AND.
BLACK LIVES MATTER CALIFORNIA
THANK YOU. ONE TWENTY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI GOOD
MORNING TERM MEMBERS OF LESLIE
VASQUEZ ON BEHALF OF THE LEAGUE
OF WOMEN VOTERS OF CALIFORNIA
IN SUPPORT. FORTY SEVEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING SHERRY
THE MAN ALWAYS TELECOM BALLY
DEBUG IN SAN JOSE CALIFORNIA IN
STRONG SUPPORT AB ONE. I'M BYE
BYE. BY NINETEEN MILLION IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. WE'RE
GOING TO LAND FIFTY FIVE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS PAUL YOUR
GOOD MORNING I'M JUST MAKING
SURE WE GOT ON RECORD IN
SUPPORT THE CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSOCIATION OF PSYCHIATRISTS
THANK YOU. THANKS FIFTY SIX
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING BRITAIN
SHARE- THE VALUE KING WITH THE
ADVANCEMENT PROJECT CALIFORNIA
AND STRONG SUPPORT. WE HAVE NO
ADDITIONAL COMMENTS FOR
SUPPORTING QUEUE AT THIS TIME.
SO HAVING HEARDFROM BUT IS
THIS GARCIA ON THE LINE. ONE
MOMENT PLEASE. AT THIS TIME I
DO NOT SEE IMAGE COURTESY
ANNOYING. THAT'S FINE I THINK-
BUT PLENTY OF US IS SUPPORT FOR
THIS BILL I HAVEN'T HEARD FROM
ALL THE SUPPORTERS WILL NOW
FOLLOW THE SAME PROCESS IN HERE
FOR MANY OPPOSITION. NOT SEEN
ANYBODY HERE THE GALLERY NOT
SEEN ANYBODY IN ROOM ONE
TWELVE- OPERATOR THE MODERATOR
COULD YOU PLEASE PROPPED
INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO TESTIFY
IN OPPOSITION. TO ONE ONE
EIGHT. THANK YOU TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION OF EIGHTY ONE ONE
EIGHT THIS PRESS ONE THEN ZERO
AT THIS TIME. AT THIS TIME WE
HAVE NO LANE TO Q. TWO STROKE
OPPOSITION. OKAY THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MODERATOR- WHAT WE'RE
GONNA DO NOW IS WE'RE GOING TO
MOVE TO- MEMBERS WISHING TO-
SPEAK- SENATOR ARCHULETA. THANK
YOU RICHARD AND I'D LIKE TO
HAVE THANK THE AUTHOR FOR
BRINGING THIS FORWARD WITH SO
MANY PEOPLE NEEDING HELP AND
SUPPORT ACROSS THE ENTIRE
STATE- MY QUESTION IS THE PILOT
PROGRAM AND GRANTS AND SO ON
DISTANT INCLUDE- ORGANIZATIONS
THAT ARE- FIVE A ONE SHE AND
REGISTER BY CITIES OR- HOW DO
YOU. GET OVER THERE SO MANY
ORGANIZATIONS NOW THEY'RE BEING
PUT TOGETHER TO HELP THE
HOMELESS AND SO ON AND THEY MAY
NOT BE SANCTIONED BY THE CITY
OR REGISTERED IS IT JUST OPENED
UP TO EVERYONE OR IS IT-
ORGANIZATIONS THAT AS I
MENTIONED FIVE OH ONE SHE OR
REGISTERED WITH THE CITY'S-
THROUGH THE CHAIR. THANK YOU
FOR THAT QUESTION THIS THE
NONPROFITS FOR NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATIONS WHO ARE
REGISTERED AS FIVE OH ONE C.
THREES AND THEY WOULD HAVE TO
BE IN PARTNERSHIP- WITH A LOCAL
JURISDICTION SOEITHER A CITY
OR A COUNTY OR DEPARTMENT
WITHIN A CITY OR A COUNTY. VERY
GOOD I'D LIKE TO MOVE THE BILL
WHEN IT'S APPROPRIATE THANK YOU
OKAY ANY OTHER COMMENTS-
SENATOR MELINDA AS- THANK YOU
MR CHAIRMAN- SO. YOU HAD A
SIMILAR BILL LAST YEAR WHICH
THE GOVERNOR VETOED- I THINK
HIS STATEMENT WAS THAT- YES WAS
IN THE APPROPRIATE LOCATION FOR
THIS TYPE OF PROGRAM AND I
DON'T SEE THAT THIS BILL
CHANGES THE LOCATION OF THIS-
CAN YOU ADDRESS THAT. YES THANK
YOU FOR THAT QUESTION- WE ARE
STILL WORKING WITH THE GOVERNOR
TO IDENTIFY- THE MOST
APPROPRIATE DEPARTMENT TO HOUSE
THIS INITIALLY THERE WERE
CONCERNS ABOUT IT BEING IN- YES
LAST YEAR OBVIOUSLY BECAUSE OF
THE PANDEMIC- AND ALL THAT- YES
WAS DEALING WITH- WE ARE
NEGOTIATING WHETHER OR NOT IT
SHOULD BE IN DEPARTMENT OF
SOCIAL SERVICES- WHICH HAS
EXPRESSED. AN INTEREST IN-
WANTING TO- MANAGE THIS
PARTICULAR PILOT PROGRAM- AND
SO THE DISCUSSIONS HAVE MORE TO
DO- WITH THAT IN ALLOCATIONS
THAT ARE IN THE STATE BUDGET.
OKAY ANYBODY ELSE CENTER WHICH
I CLOSE WE HAVE A MOTION GO
AHEAD WHICH I CLOSE. YES I AM I
WANT TO THANK THE COMMITTEE FOR
OF THEIR QUESTIONS I WANT TO
ADD THAT DURING THE COURSE OF
LAST YEAR AND THIS YEAR WE
HAVE. HUNDREDS OF CORPORATIONS
NONPROFITS AND INDIVIDUALS-
SUPPORTING THIS BILL AND WHILE
WE HAVE SEEN A NUMBER OF THESE
KINDS OF EFFORTS CROPPING UP
LOCALLY THIS IS AN OPPORTUNITY
FOR THE STATE- TO STEP IN. AND
SHOW SUPPORT AS WELL I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
IPHONE. THANK YOU SENATOR- THE
BILL'S BEEN MOVED BY CENTER
ARCH ALETTA THE MOTION IS TO
PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
DOT I THOUGHT I'D NIELSEN. ALAN
ARCHULETA ARCHULETA I'D BECKER
FORGES LIVE BORDERS HI BRADFORD
LASER EYE LASER EYE WESO JONES
HI JONES HI KEN LONGER I
CANNOT- I MIRANDA'S. ACCORDING
TO NOW HI ACCORDING TO YOU KNOW
I. RUBIO WILL HI WELCOME HI
IT'S GOT EIGHT VOTES- WILL
PLACES BILL ON CALL- MEMBERS
EIGHT- WE ARE GOING TO NOW MOVE
TO THE CONSENT CALENDAR-
THERE'S BEEN AN UPDATE TO THE
CONCERT CUT CALENDAR- FILE ITEM
NUMBER NINE. ELEVEN AB ELEVEN
SEVENTY THREE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
COOPER IS NO LONGER ON CONSENT
THEY'RE NOW FIFTEEN BILLS I CAN
SENT IN THEIR FILE ITEM NUMBER
TWO THREE FOUR FIVE SIX.
211-213-1617 NINETEEN TWENTY
TWENTY ONE AND TWENTY THREE.
ALL GOOD BIPARTISAN BILLS. WE
HAVE A MOTION BY A SENATOR WILL
TO MOVE THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
SECTOR PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
DOT HI START II NIELSEN. YEAH
PHIL SENTENCING LR NELSON HI
ALAN ARCHULETA ARCHULETA I'D
BECKER BARGES PLYING BORDERS HI
BRADFORD LASER EYE LASER EYE
WESO JONES HI JONES HI KEN
LONGER I AM LONGER ON THE LIST
BELINDA'S I PUT INTO NOW. HI
FOURTEEN TO NO HI RUBIO WILL.
WELCOME BYE. THAT'S TEN ZERO
UNCLE TEN VOTES IN THE BILL'S
ON CALL WHEN I MOVED TO FILE
ITEM NUMBER SEVEN A. B. SIX
FIVE SEVEN ASSEMBLYMEMBER
COOPER GOOD MORNING YOU MAY
BEGIN. GOOD MORNING THIS IS
YOUR COLLEAGUES THE STATE CIVIL
SERVICE ACT ESTABLISHES
STANDARDS FOR THE USE OF
PERSONAL SERVICES CONTRACTS BY
STATE AGENCIES WITH PRESCRIBED
CONDITIONS ARE MET. THIS IS A
PERSONAL SERVICES CONTRACT
SHOULD BE USED SPARINGLY WHEN
THERE HAD FUNDED FULL TIME
POSITIONS NOT BEING FILLED.
THIS IS SPECIALLY TRUE WHEN
THOSE VACANCIES ARE HEALTH CARE
PROVIDERS SUCH AS PHYSICIANS
SURGEONS PSYCHOLOGIST AND
DENTIST. WITH PROFESSIONALS ARE
CONTRACTED CONSISTENTLY
SOMETIME WITHOUT DUE CAUSE.
WE'RE BACK TO THE QUALITY OF
CARE TO PATIENTS A. B. SIX FIVE
SEVEN PROVIDES PROTECTIONS AND
TRANSPARENCY TO THE STATE'S-HEALTH CARE SERVICES AND
PROFESSIONALS BY PROHIBITING A
STATE AGENCY FROM ENTERING INTO
A CONTRACT WITH PROFESSIONAL
FOR A PERIOD OF MORE THAN THREE
HUNDRED SIXTY FIVE CONSECUTIVE
DAYS. THREE SIXTY FIVE NOT
SIXTY DAYS IN A TWENTY FOUR
MONTH PERIOD. THE FUNNY
PROFESSIONAL TO INCLUDE AMONG
OTHERS A PHYSICIAN. SURGEON
DENTIST AND CLINICAL
PSYCHOLOGIST. LAWYER TO
INCLUDING REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS REGARDING THESE
CONTRACTS WITH ME IT IS
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT FOR
DOCTORS TO HER BUSTY PRESIDENT
MOON OF AMERICAN PHYSICIANS AND
DENTISTS ASKING LOCAL TWENTY
SIX AND DOCTOR RYAN KIM BOARD
MEMBER. OF AMERICAN PHYSICIANS
AND DENTISTS. WITNESSES CAN
PLEASE PROCEED. MODERATOR WE
HAVE THE MAIN WITNESSES ONLINE.
CLOSE TO BE OPEN AT THIS TIME
PLEASE GO AHEAD. AND WE HAVE NO
WITNESSES FOR THAT BILL. WE'RE
GONNA FOLLOW THE SAME PROCESS
WILL MOVE FOR ANYBODY IN
SUPPORT OF A. B. SIX FIVE
SEVEN- THERE'S NOBODY HERE IN
THE GALLERY AND- NOBODY IN ROOM
ONE TWELVE SO MODERATOR CAN WE
PLEASE- CHECK THE LINE AND SEE
IF ANYBODY'S WISHING TO
TESTIFY. IN SUPPORT OF SIX FIVE
SEVEN. YES AND LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOUR IN THE
SUPPORT OF EIGHTY SIX FIVE
SEVEN PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT
THIS TIME. ONE CONNECT AND
SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO
AT THIS TIME. ONE MOMENT PLEASE
ONE WHAT PARKER'S. AT THE. JUST
ANOTHER MOMENT PLEASE. THE
REGULAR LINE NUMBER THIRTY SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
MISTER CHAIR CHAIRMAN DODD AND
SENATOR BUT THAT HE DOES CHIP
PETA I'M EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF
THE UNION OF AMERICAN
PHYSICIANS AND DENTISTS WE ARE
NOT REALLY ABOUT ME AND WE ARE
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF A. B. SIX
FIVE SEVEN BY MISTER COOPER.
THANK YOU SO MUCH. THANK YOU.
ONE MOMENT. NEXT STORYLINE
EMBER SIXTY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR
GEORGE OSBORNE FOR YOU EIGHTY
EIGHT IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
EIGHTY SIX FIFTY SEVEN THANK
YOU. MISTER CHAIRPERSON AT THIS
TIME WE HAVE NO OTHER SECURE.
OKAY HAVING HEARD FROM ALL
SPORTS NOW FOLLOW THE SAME
PROCESS IN HERE FOR MANY
OPPOSITION IS THERE ANY
OPPOSITION IN THE GALLERY
SEEING NONE. ALSO SEE NONE IN
ROOM ONE TWELVE SO MODERATOR
WILL FOLLOW THE SAME PROCESS IS
THERE ANYBODY ON THE LINE
WISHING TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION A BABY SIX FIFTY
SEVEN. THANK YOU AND LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU ARE AN
OPPOSITION EIGHTY SIX FIVE
SEVEN PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT
THIS TIME. ONE CANNOT
OPPOSITION EIGHTY SIX FIVE
THOUSAND PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO. MR SHEPHERDS WE HAVE NO
ONE IN QUEUE AT THIS TIME THANK
YOU MODERATOR AT THIS POINT IN
TIME WILL NOW BRING THE
DISCUSSION BACK TO THE MEMBERS.
ANY MEMBERS WISHING TO ADDRESS
US- CENTER BLOOD TESTS. WHICH
IS A POSITION- BOARD DECIDES.
OKAY THANK YOU SO MUCH MISTER
CHAIR- ASSEMBLYMAN COOPER NICE
TO SEE YOU AND THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING YOUR BILL FORWARD BUT
I DO HAVE A QUESTION ABOUT IT.
YOU KNOW THE FACT THAT WE HAVE
A SHORTAGE OF HEALTHCARE
PROFESSIONALS IN CALIFORNIA
WHICH IS WHY WE OFTEN TIMES TRY
TO PASS BILLS THAT- YOU KNOW
WE'LL HAVE NEW NEW MEDICAL
SCHOOLS AND OTHER. WAYS TO
EXPAND. THE NUMBER OF EMPLOYEES
THAT WE HAVE IN THE MEDICAL
FIELD SO THIS SEEMS TO LIMIT
THAT AND I'M CURIOUS AS TO-
WHAT'S YOUR REASONING IS BEHIND
THAT IS THERE SOME. GENESIS TO
THIS BILL THAT YOU DIDN'T
OUTLINE IN YOUR OPENING
STATEMENT FURNITURE CONCERNS
WHAT IS YOUR TEMPORARY
CONTRACTS AND USING SOME FOLKS
GO OVER A YEAR. SO OTHERS OF
SHORTAGE- IT DOESN'T IT DOESN'T
QUITE TAKE A YEAR TO GET
SOMEBODY ON BOARD WITH THAT
SOURCING IT USED TO BYPASS. THE
OF TWO POSITIONS ARE DENNIS
WORKING SIDE BY SIDE. IT IS
PERSONAL THE TEMPORARIES
PROFESSIONAL CONTRACT IS MAKING
SUBSTANTIALLY MORE THAN THE
STATE EMPLOYEES. THAT'S THAT'S
BEEN A BIG ISSUE SO THERE'S
BEEN SOME ABUSE THERE WITH THAT
SAID ARE YOU SAYING THAT WE ARE
PAYING THEM THESE- OTHER FOLKS
MORE. THAN WE'RE PAYING THE
STATE WORKERS CORRECT- THAT
SEEMS ODD THAT THE STATE WOULD
PAY MORE FOR PRIVATE.
CONTRACTORS THAN IT WOULD FOR
STATE EMPLOYEES A- YOU'RE SURE
DOES LOVE THING SOMETIMES YES.
OKAY AND I WISH MY- WITNESSES
WERE HERE BECAUSE THEY CAN GO
INTO MUCH MORE DEPTH THAN I CAN
ON THE ISSUE MODERATOR LET'S
CHECK AND SEE IF THOSE
WITNESSES ARE ON THE LINE IS
THERE ANYWAY THIS IS- THAT ARE
ON THE LINE. WE DIDN'T BEAT
WERE ABLE TO GET BEFORE THE
COLLAPSE OF THE QUESTION. ONE
MOMENT PLEASE. ELIZABETH YOUR
WITNESS YOUR LINE IS OPEN AT
THIS TIME. AND I DO NOT SEE ANY
OKAY SO I JUST WANNA DO THERE'S
GOING TO BE THE LAST WORD I
GUESS. OKAY WELL I DO AND
THAT'S UNFORTUNATE THAT YOUR
WITNESSES WERE ABLE TOBE ON
MAYBE THEY'LL POP ON HERE
SHORTLY BECAUSE I HEARD YOU
TALK ABOUT FIDUCIARY CONCERNS
IN AN OFTEN TIMES IT HAPPENS
IT'S MORE COST EFFECTIVE. FOR
THE STATE TO DO SOMETHING LIKE
THIS IN ADDITION TO IT JUST
BEING MORE EFFECTIVE BECAUSE OF
THE LACK OF PERSONNEL. BUT I
HEARD TWO THINGS ONE IT WAS A
FIDUCIARY REASON AND THEN I
HEARD. THAT THE STATUS. PAYING
MORE THAN WE NEED TO SELL WHICH
IS IT. WHAT WHAT WHAT IS IT IN
A GOOD SHIFT CONTRACTS ARE NOT
SUBJECT TO CIVIL SERVICE RULES.
WE GO OUTSIDE. I'M SORRY SAY
AGAIN I HEAR THE FIRST PART. OF
THE CONTRACT NEGOTIATED
CONTRACTS AND THEY'RE NOT
SUBJECT TO CIVIL SERVICE RULES.
BUT THE STATE PERSONNEL BOARD
STILL HAS TO MAKE SURE THAT
THEY ARE FOLLOWING THE RULES
AND THE UNIONS CAN STILL
CONTEST THOSE THOSE CONTRACTS
RIGHT. UNDER THE CURRENT LAW
THEY CAN BUT WITH THESE
CONTRACTS- OBVIOUSLY THEIR PAY
MORE SO THAT THAT THAT IS
FACTUAL. OKAY THANK YOU THANK
YOU MR CHAIRMAN. THANK YOU
CENTER BORDERS. I THINK MY
COLLEAGUE- POSE QUESTION THAT I
WAS GOING TO POSE IT'S GOOD TO
SEE YOU AS A MEMBER- I KNOW
HE'S A VERY THOUGHTFUL
LEGISLATOR- AS I MENTIONED- MY
COLLEAGUE POSE THE QUESTIONS
THAT I WANTED TO POSE BUT-
MAYBE I'LL JUST FOLLOW THIS
LAST RABBIT DOWN THE HOLE. THE
THIS BILL WOULD REQUIRE
INFORMATION BE SHARED WITH THE
UNIONS THAT REPRESENT THE
EMPLOYEE BLOCKS- CAN YOU
EXPLAIN. WHY THAT IS ESSENTIAL
IF WE'RE LOOKING AT SHORT TERM.
CONTRACTS. WHY WOULD IT BE
ESSENTIAL THAT THAT INFORMATION
BE CONVEYED TO THE UNION. THAT
REPRESENTS THAT EMPLOYEE WALK
BECAUSE ONE OF THESE FOLKS ARE
BEING PAID THAT'S A GREAT
QUESTION BECAUSE THEY'VE
THEY'VE CIRCUMVENTED. THE
SYSTEM AND THAT'S REASONABLE TO
BEING PAID HIGHER BECAUSE- WITH
THE CIVIL SERVICE SYSTEM THERE
IS NEGOTIATED BUT IT'S OPENS
THEY'RE PAYING MORE I REALIZE A
SHORTAGE OF DOCTORS BUT- TO DO
THE SAME JOB AND GET PAID
SUBSTANTIALLY MORE- IT DOESN'T.
FIT WELL TO OUR DOCKS IN OUR
POSITIONS THAT- DO IT FROM. SAY
RIGHT NOW THAT'S REALLY THE BIG
ISSUE. WHAT AND I WOULDN'T BE
SURPRISED IF SHORT TERM
EMPLOYEES ARE PAID MORE THAN
STATE EMPLOYEES. BY THE VERY
NATURE OF A SHORT TERM CONTRACT
YOU'RE SATISFYING IN. AN
IMMEDIATE NEED. HI OF COURSE
THE PREMIUMS GO UP WITH
SOMETHING LIKE THAT. I GUESS MY
CONCERN AND I KNOW YOU DO YOUR
HOMEWORK- WHAT WE LEARNED FROM
THE PANDEMIC. IS THAT WE NEED
TO HAVE A MORE NIMBLE HEALTH
SYSTEM. FIVE BECAUSE- YOU KNOW.
EXTERNALITIES IN THINGS THAT
CANNOT BE FORESEEN- COME ABOUT
WE DON'T KNOW WHERE THE
PANDEMIC IS GOING TO GO NEXT.
BUT IF WE CURTAIL. THE ABILITY
OF THE STATE TO CONTRACT OUT
FOR THESE SERVICES. I'M AFRAID
THAT WE'RE GONNA BE CUTTING OUR
NOSE TO SPITE OUR FACE IN NOT
LEARNING LESSONS. SHOULD BE
LEARNED FROM OVER THE LAST YEAR
AND A HALF SO- I APPRECIATE THE
WORK YOU DO- THERE MIGHT JUST.
BE A PHILOSOPHICAL DIFFERENCE
ON THIS ONE MY FRIENDS. SURE IT
WOULD BE FILLED WITH C. C. R.
THAT HAVE BEEN PSYCHIATRIST
THAT MADE- THREE OR FOUR
THOUSAND DOLLARS. ON A CONTRACT
SERVICE LIKE THIS. IS A- FULL
TIME- SEE IF YOUR EMPLOYEES
THAT MAKES IT'S ACTUALLY LESS.
SO THIS THIS IS UNFAIR VIEWS
BUT IT'S WIDESPREAD. THIS IS
THANK YOU THANK YOU I THINK
WHEN YOU ARE GOING TO CONTRACT
OUT. FOR SHORT TERM NOT LONG
TERM BUT FOR SHORT TERM
CONTRACTS YOU WERE FILLING
SPECIFIC GAPS. IN THAT NATION
QUALIFICATION. NATURALLY WAS
PROBABLY GOING TO DEMAND A
HIGHER PAY THAN A FULL TIME
LONG TERM CONTRACT FROM AN
EMPLOYEE BLOCK. INTERNATIONALLY
RIGHT AND THAT'S WHY WE
SPECIFIED HERE. THEY CAN'T
CONTRACT FOR MORE THAN A YEAR
SO I THINK A YEAR IS
SUBSTANTIAL TIME TO TRY TO FIND
SOMEONE FOR A YEAR OR THIRTY
FIVE DAYS IN A IN A TWO MONTH
TWENTY FOUR MONTH PERIOD. WE'RE
TRYING TO NEARLY DIVINE THAT.
IT ALSO SHOULD BE POINTED OUT-
DENTURES THAT CENTER MELINDA'S
WILL PROCEED THIS IS A- GIVEN
HER EMOTIONS ON. A REGULAR
BASIS IN OUR SESSIONS. BUT
SPECIFIES THAT NOTHING SHALL BE
CONSTRUED TO LIMIT THE
GOVERNOR'S AUTHORITY TO SUSPEND
STATUTES.DURING A STATE OF
EMERGENCY. SO THERE IS- ESCAPE
HATCH THERE IF WE- DO HAVE
EMERGENCIES. CENTER LASER.
THANK YOU AT CHER DIED
ASSEMBLYMAN I THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING THAT BILL TO US IT
STIMULATES AN IMPORTANT DEBATE-
AND FOR ME I'M STRUGGLING ON ON
THE BILL BECAUSE FOR A NUMBER
OF REASONS BUT- HOPING THAT YOU
COULD- BE CLEARER ABOUT THE
EXTENT OF THE PROBLEM I MEAN WE
ALWAYS HAVE ANECDOTES
THROUGHOUT OUR- WHERE THERE
SHOULD BE SOME PROBLEMS BUT-
I'M TRYING TO UNDERSTAND THE-
EXTENT OF THE PROBLEM AS YOU
SEE IT. WHAT WHAT DATA DO YOU
HAVE TO SHOW- THAT THAT THAT-
THAT WE'RE NOT FOLLOWING THE
RULES BECAUSE THE RULES ARE
CLEAR HERE. THAT A PROPOSED
CONTRACT SHOULD RESULT IN AN
OVERALL COST SAVINGS TO THE
STATE WHAT WHAT'S HAPPENING IS
THE SHORT TERM CONTRACTS
TURNING INTO LONG TERM
CONTRACTS THAT'S BEEN A BIG
ISSUE AND- MY WITNESSES WHO I
HAVE NO IDEA WHAT THEY ARE
HERE- CAN ACTUALLY TESTIFY THAT
BUT IT'S- IT'S BEEN GOING ON A
REGULAR BASIS IS EXACERBATED.
EXACERBATED BY THE SWORD OF
QUALIFIED PROFESSIONALS BUT
THERE'S NOTHING IN THE- IN THE
ANALYSIS THAT PROVIDES ANY
SPECIFIC DATA- I COULD GO TO
THAT COMMITTEE CANCELED AND ASK
IF HE IS AWARE OF ANY DATA.
PROVIDED TO HIM. IT SHOWS THE
EXTENT OF THIS PROBLEM. CAN I
ASK MISTER CHAIRMAN CAN I ASK
THEIR CONSOLE THERE'S BEEN ANY
DATA HE'S AWARE OF. THAT SHOWS
THE EXTENT OF THIS PROBLEM. YES
AS AS A WE ASKED A DISEASE
RATHER INFORMATION. CENTER
UNFORTUNATELY AT THIS TIME WE
HAVEN'T BEEN ABLE TO GET THAT
INFORMATION FROM THEM- AND THAT
THAT THAT'S WHAT MAKES ME
STRUGGLE WITH THIS BILL BECAUSE
I APPRECIATE THE GOOD
INTENTIONS OF THE AUTHOR. BUT
YOU KNOW WE GET HIT ALL THE
TIME ABOUT A LACK OF EFFICIENCY
IN STATE GOVERNMENT. SO WE SET
RULES THAT SAY CONTRACTING OUT
GONNA HAPPEN IN LIMITED WAYS.
BUT YOU HAVE TO PROVE THAT IT'S
GOING TO PROVIDE AN OVERALL
COST SAVINGS. I MEAN THAT'S
WHAT THAT'S WHAT IT SAYS HERE
ON IN THE ANALYSIS- AND LISTEN
I HEAR THAT I HEAR THE APPEAL
ABOUT A YEAR BUT NOW WE CAN'T
EVEN GET A REGULATION OF THE
STATED A YEAR. ON LABOR
VIOLATIONS- DURING A PANDEMIC.
SO WE HAVE STRUGGLE AT ALL
LEVELS OF GOVERNMENT TO TRY TO
MAKE IT MORE EFFICIENT. AND SO
I'M WONDERING IF WE'LL BUY YOU
KNOW THAT THIS BILL IS SO IS SO
BROAD BASED IN ITS APPLICATION
THAT I CAN HAVE A LOT OF
UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES WHICH
IS WHY I GO BACK TO. TRYING TO
UNDERSTAND WHERE IS THE ABUSE
HAPPENING- AND IT DOES SEEM TO
ME THAT THAT THAT MAY BE THE
RIGHT. IN A TWO STEP THE FIRST
STEP IS REALLY TO FIND OUT THE
EXTENT OF THE PROBLEM AND A
BILL THAT. SAYS THAT WE NEED
THE STATE TO REPORT IN ON ALL
THE EXAMPLES OF CONTRACTING OUT
BEYOND THE YEAR. SO WE COULD
SEE THAT DATA AND THAT ABUSE
MIGHT BE THE- THE FIRST STEP OF
A TWO STEP HERE. TO ADVANCE THE
BILL THAT YOU HAVE BROUGHT
FORWARD BECAUSE I THINK IT HAS
THE BEST OF INTENTIONS- BUT IT
SEEMS THAT IT'S ON A FOUNDATION
THAT DOESN'T APPEAR TO BE.
CLEAR. TO ME AT LEAST AT THIS
POINT IN TIME. YOUR COMMENTS IN-
CHAIR I'VE BEEN TOLD. DOCTOR
CAME IN THE LINE. IS IT
POSSIBLE TO GO TO HIM. THANK
YOU ASSEMBLYMEMBER DOCTOR WAS A
DOCTOR KING I'M SORRY DR KIM.
DR KID CAN YOU PLEASE PROCEED.
BUT I'M NOT SURE IF. SO MAYBE
CHARTER BUSES CAN YOU HEAR ME.
JUST GONNA TALK ABOUT THAT
HELLO OKAY CAN YOU HEAR ME-
CHAIRMAN YES WE CAN'T PLEASE
PROCEED. OKAY I'M THE PRESIDENT
OF THE UNION- GOOD AFTERNOON
I'M DOCTOR STUART BUCKY AND
PRESIDENT OF THE UAE PD THE
UNION OF AMERICAN PHYSICIANS
DENTISTS. BUT I'M A STRONG
SUPPORTER OF EIGHTY SIX FIFTY
SEVEN. THIS BILL AND SIGNED
INTO LAW WILL IMPROVE THE
HIRING PROCESS OF THE DOCTORS
DENTISTS AND PSYCHOLOGISTS AND
WILL REDUCE THE CIVIL SERVANTS
VACANCY RATE. AND SAVE MILLIONS
FOR CALIFORNIA TAXPAYERS. HI I
DID HEAR OF ONE OF THE- MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE SAY WHAT'S THE
PROBLEM HERE. IS THERE A USES
THERE'S DEFINITELY ABUSE. FOR
DECADES THE STATUS CONTRACTED
OUT OUR BARGAINING UNIT BACON
CHEESE TOO EXPENSIVE PRIVATE
REGISTRIES. AND THE NUMBERS ARE
ENORMOUS- I'LL TELL YOU IN A
SECOND OUR CIVIL SERVICE
WORKFORCE IS LYNDALL DOWN TO
IT- SMALL GROUP OF PEOPLE FOR A
VARIETY OF REASONS. MINIMAL
SALARY INCREASES VERY ANEMIC
RECRUITING EFFORTS BY THE
STATE. THE STATE WILL CLAIM
THAT THEY PREFER CIVIL SERVICE
DOCTORS OVER CONTRACT IT'S
BEHAVIOR INDICATE OTHERWISE
WHETHER IT'S NEGOTIATING OUR
AMMO USER MEETING WITH THE U.
H. P. D. N. CONTRACTING OUT
COMMITTEE LITTLE CURVATURES PAY
TO OUR RECOMMENDATIONS. NO
WONDER THE CDCR PSYCHIATRY
VACANCY. RATE IS NEARLY 50%
WE'VE TRIED PRETTY APPOINTMENTS
AT AT A BASE RATE. NO NO EXTRA
BONUSES THE STATE DOESN'T WANT
TO GIVE IT TO US. THE VACANCY
RATE THAT SOME D. S. H. STATE
OCTOBER IS THAT 80% SO ON THE
OTHER HAND AT THIS YOU SEE THEM
GIVING THE CONTRACTORS TWO
HUNDRED SEVENTY FIVE DOLLARS AN
HOUR. PLUS A SIXTY FIVE DOLLAR
ADMINISTRATIVE FEE WHICH IS
QUITE THE SALARY OF OUR
PSYCHIATRIST. CONTRACTORS MAKE
UP TO SEVENTY TO EIGHTY FIVE
THOUSAND DOLLARS ONE GUY MADE
EIGHTY FIVE THOUSAND DOLLARS IN
ONE MONTH. ACCORDING TO THE
DATA SUPPLIED BY THE STATE SO
WE HAVE THE DATA TO BACK UP.
THAT BETWEEN THE CDC ARE
CONTRACTED TO DSHS COSTING
ABOUT A HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS
A YEAR ANNUALLY. FOR THESE
PEOPLE ALL THESE CONTRACTS TO
KEEP RE UPPING THE PLANNERS
EMERGE. TAKE OUR JOBS AWAY FROM
PEOPLE WHO KNOW THEIR PATIENTS
BETTER THAN THE CONTRACTORS
KNOW THEIR INSTITUTIONS. AND
THERE'S AN ADDICTION GOING ON-
I DON'T WANT TO YOU KNOW SIR
MY- HYPOTHESIZE WHY IT SHOULD
EXIST WITH PRIVATE REGISTRIES.
OF CHARGE AN ENORMOUS AMOUNT OF
MONEY AND WHO DON'T PROVIDE THE
SAME SERVICE WE DON'T PROVIDE
ADEQUATE. AS GOOD SERVICES AS
PEOPLE WHO KNOW. THE PATIENTS
THEMSELVES- ACTUALLY IN
CONFLICT WITH THE GOALS OF THE
PRODUCT AND COLEMAN LAWSUITS
WHICH IS. KNOWN BY. YOU KNOW
GOOD PEOPLE SERVICE WITH
CONSISTENT. CONTINUITY OF CARE
AND SO SIMPLE SERVICE PROVIDER
COMPANY CARE CONTRACTORS LESS
SO. WELL ACTUALLY FOR TWENTY
TWO ON THE ONE IT'S UP TO
INCENTIVIZE DOCTORS BY CREATING
A REGISTRY. EIGHTY SIX FIFTY
SEVEN TO THE COPPERY BOOK IN
THE BOOK AND BY RESTRICTING THE
TOTAL TIME THREE HUNDRED SIXTY
FIVE DAYS A YEAR FOR
CUMULATIVELY OVER TWO YEARS. WE
GOTTA STOP THIS ADDICTION WE
GOTTA STOP THIS MONEY WASTE WE
GOT A WIN PROVED. THERE WE CAN
SUPPLY YOU WITH THE DATA. AS
ONE OF YOUR MEMBERS SUGGESTED
BUT IT IS A REAL PROBLEM AND
IT'S GETTING WORSE THANK YOU- I
HOPE YOU WILL- AND I BOTH
PLEASE STAY ON THE LINE BECAUSE
WE HAVE I THINK SENATOR GLAZER
WOULD LIKE- TO ASK A QUESTION.
THANK YOU DEAR DIARY THANK YOU
TO THE UNION PRESIDENT
PROVIDING THAT THAT THAT
IMPORTANT PERSPECTIVE. THE
ISSUES THAT YOU RAISE A THESE
ARE ISSUES THAT ARE SUBJECT TO
COLLECTIVE BARGAINING I ASSUME
YOU CAN GAUGE IN DISCUSSIONS
WITH THE ADMINISTRATION DURING
THAT PROCESS- WE CERTAINLY AT
WE ASKED FOR ADDITIONAL
APPOINTMENTS AS I MENTIONED WE
COULD PROVIDE. WHICH WOULD
PROVIDE A SERVICE IN FACT WE
WOULD WE WOULD HAVE YOU KNOW
WELL. NO EXTRA PREMIUM FOR
STAYING LATE WORKING AN EXTRA
TWENTY HOURS PROVIDING EXTRA
SERVICES AT NO COST TO THE
STATE THE STATE HAS NOT
COOPERATED THE INDIVIDUAL
PRESENCE WILL NOT GRANT THIS
FORCE SO WE'RE PULLING OUR HAIR
OUT. GIVING BETTER SERVICE AT A
LOWER RATE AND THE STATE STILL
GOES ON AND TIRED THESE PEOPLE
AT TWICE THE RATE MAKES NO
BUSINESS SENSE AND ONE ONE
FOOTNOTE ONE FINAL FOLLOW UP
QUESTION IF I MAY WHICH IS
THAT- WHEN YOU TALK ABOUT. THAT
YET THE STATES REQUIRED TO-
SPECIFY THE COST SAVINGS AND I
GUESS I WOULD NOTE THAT WHEN
YOU TALK ABOUT COMPARING A
CONTRACTOR WITH AN EMPLOYEE
THAT YOU HAVE TO TAKE INTO
ACCOUNT. ALL THE PAY AND
BENEFITS THAT THAT STATE
EMPLOYEES MAKING SO ONCE AGAIN
THERE'S NOTHING IN THE RECORD.
HERE THAT. PROVIDES A- CLEARED
DATA THE PNG AND FOR THE KIDS
THAT WE HAVE READ. BY HERE'S
WHAT YOU NEED EVEN WITH. HIS
EVEN WITH. ARE YEAH. I
INTERESTED I TOTALLY GONNA IT I
HAVE BEEN SO MUCH ELSE CAN. TO
ENGAGE IN A DEBATE IF THEY WISH
BUT- THERE'S NOT IN THE RECORD
THAT PROVIDES ANY
SUBSTANTIATION FOR THE CLAIMS
THAT. THE WITNESSES MADE AND I
WOULD ALSO NOTE THAT- HE'S
ACKNOWLEDGED THAT THIS IS
SUBJECT TO COLLECTIVE
BARGAINING WHICH I'VE STRONGLY
SUPPORT. WHERE THE EMPLOYEE
GROUP AND THE ADMINISTRATION
ENGAGED IN THESE TYPES OF
CONVERSATIONS AND- THAT'S A
PROCESS I THINK WE SHOULD
RESPECT. I MEAN TIME AND TIME
AGAIN MEASURES F CALM BEFORE
THIS LEGISLATURE THAT
CIRCUMVENT THE COLLECTIVE
BARGAINING PROCESS THAT
EVERYONE CLAIMS RITUALS TO
HONOR AND RESPECT. AND THIS
SEEMS TO BE ANOTHER EXAMPLE OF
THAT UNFORTUNATELY I THINK IF
WE HAVE CLEAR REVIEWS THAT IT'S
UP TO US AS POLICY MAKERS TO
MAKE CHANGES BUT I SAY AGAIN
WE'RE ON THE RECORD. IS THERE
TO SHOW THAT THE STATE IS NOT
FOLOWING THE LAW ABOUT
EFFICIENCY WITH THAT MISTER
CHAIRMAN THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY THANK YOU ANY OTHER
MEMBERS WISHING TO ADDRESS-
THERE'S A GLARE HERE SO PLEASE
RAISE YOUR HAND IF YOU'RE- NOT
SEEING ANYBODY. IS THERE A
MOTION. TO APPROVE THIS. MORE
THE BELL. THE MOTION BY SENATOR
RUBIO THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED BY THE CORPORATIONS
COMMITTEE BEFORE WE TAKE THE
VOTE- MISTER COOPER ARE YOU
TAKING A MOMENT TO ACCEPT
COVERED CALIFORNIA FROM THIS
BILL. YES OKAY THEY'LL BE DULY
NOTED THANK YOU- WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE THIS I WOULD- ACTUALLY
SAYS RALPH LOTS OF MILITARY
GENERAL HE LEFT SIDE I PICKED
UP THE BALL FOREMAN CAN YOU GET
FOR A- GENERAL BATA. AND IT'S
MORALE ISSUES IF YOUR DOCTOR
WORKING SIDE BY SIDE. AND
YOU'RE MAKING MORE. THE GUY
NEXT TO THE IT'S REALLY A
MATTER OF FAIRNESS AND YOU KNOW
ONE THING ABOUT THE STATE IN
COLLECTIVE BARGAINING. AND
WE'RE TALKING POSITIONS- THE
STATE. HEY I CAN'T FIND A
BETTER WAY TO SAY IT SUCKS I
WAS CHIPS UP FOR BEST PICTURE
PERS WHEN YOU LOOK AT
COMPARISONS THAT'S WHY SHE
WORKING FOR MUNICIPALITY OR
SOMEWHERE ELSE BESIDES THE
STATE. THE PAY AND BENEFITS ARE
BETTER. IN A WIDE VARIETY OF
POSITIONS SO IT IS EMBLEMATIC
OF THE MISSION OF THE STATES
ARE RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL-
THANK YOU SO MEMBER COOPER THE
BILL'S BEEN MOVED BY SENATOR
RUBIO THE MOTION IS TO PASS. AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE SECTOR PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. DOT I. DOT I. NIELSEN
NO YES AND NO ALAN ARCHULETA.
ARCHULETA I'D BECKER BORDERS NO
BORDERS NO BRADFORD. GLAZER
YEAH. HELLO POLICE ARE NO
CLOSER NO LESS SO. JONES NO JON
SNOW CAN LONGER MELENDEZ NO
BELINDA'S NO PORT INTO NOW. HI
ACCORDING TO NOTE HEIGHT RUBIO
HI RUBIO I WILL. THAT'S TWO TO
FIVE TERMINAL CALL. IF THE BILL
HAS FOUR VOTES TO FIVE NO VOTES
THAT WILL PLACES GO ON CALL. WE
WILL NOW MOVE TO FILE ITEM
NUMBER EIGHT. AB TEN SEVENTY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER COOPER YOU MAYBE
GET. THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN VERS
A B. TEN SEVENTY WILL SIMPLY
ALLOW DISTILLED SPIRITS
MANUFACTURERS. PROVIDE UP TO
TWELVE OUTDOOR PATIO UMBRELLAS
A YEAR. THE YEAH HUNDRED FIFTY
DOLLARS EACH TO LOCAL
RESTAURANTS THE BILL CONTAINS A
THREE YEAR SUNSET. THIS BILL
PROHIBITS ALCOHOL WHOLESALER
UNDERWRITE THE COST OF THESE
UMBRELLAS IN WHOLE OR IN PART.
THE BILL ALSO PROVIDES A
MANUFACTURER OR IMPORTER FROM
CONDITIONING THE GIFT OF
UMBRELLAS ON A PURCHASE OF THE
PRODUCT. OR RETAILER FROM
CONDITIONING THEIR PURCHASE A
PRODUCT ON RECEIPT OF GIFTS TO
THE BRAILLE US. DEPENDENT MAKE
THE RESTAURANT HOSPITALITY
INDUSTRY WHERE ONE OF THE WORST
BUSINESS SECTORS HIT
ECONOMICALLY. RESTAURANTS AND
BARS ARE NOT JUST STARTED TO
COME BACK TO LIFE AN OUTDOOR
DINING IS A CRITICAL COMPONENT
TO THEIR SUCCESSFUL RECOVERY.
THIS BILL SIMPLY HELP TO GET
OUR RESTAURANTS AND BARS UP ON
THEIR FEET AGAIN AND LEVY AT A.
COST OF THEM IS THE RECOVERY. I
STATE FOR THE THREE. AND I'VE
WOULDN'T WITH ME- JOHN LATIMER.
THERE'S A LOT OF OUR WELCOME
BACK TO THE BUILDING HE MAYBE
GET. THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS JOHN LATIMER ON BEHALF
OFDIAGEO WERE THE WORLD'S
LARGEST DISTILLED SPIRITS
MANUFACTURER- OUR COMPANY ALONG
WITH ALL THE OTHER BEVERAGE
MANUFACTURERS WORK VERY CLOSELY
WITH OUR RESTAURANT PARTNERS
THROUGHOUT THE PANDEMIC AND IT
BECAME CLEAR THAT MANY OF THEM
WERE STRUGGLING WITH THEIR
MEANS TO. MOVE THEIR OPERATION
OUTSIDE. FINDING WAYS TO ALLOW
THEIR PATRONS TO DINE YOUKNOW
SAFELY DRYLY UNDER AN UMBRELLA
WAS WAS ONE OF THE ADDITIONAL
EXPENSES THAT THEY BORE. WE
WENT TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
ALCOHOLIC BEVERAGE CONTROL
ASKED LAST YEAR WHETHER THIS
WAS SOMETHING WE COULD DO. WHAT
WE CAN PROVIDE THEM WITH THIS
BENEFIT TO BE ABLE TO MOVE
THEIR BUSINESSES OUTSIDE. AND
UNFORTUNATELY THEY SAID NO WE
NEED TO COME IN AND RUN A PIECE
OF LEGISLATION TO GET THAT
SPECIFIC STATUTORY AUTHORITY SO
WE DID THAT- WE HAVE A- IN IN
THE ASSEMBLY AMENDED THE BILL
TO. CREATE A SUNSET DATE SINCE
WE ALL HOPE THIS PANDEMIC IS
GONNA PASSES BY AT SOME POINT
IN THE SUNSET DATE IS THREE
YEARS FOM NOW- BUT IS
IMPORTANT MEASURE MOVING
FORWARD TO HELP OUR- RESTAURANT
PARTNERS BE ABLE TO MAINTAIN
THEIR BUSINESSES. AND OUTSIDE
KEEP THEIR EMPLOYEES EMPLOYED.
AND OF THE PATRONS AN
OPPORTUNITY TO COME BACK TO A
LITTLE BIT OF LIFE IS NORMAL SO
WE APPRECIATE. THE SUPPORT OF
THE COMMITTEE THANK YOU. THANK
YOU MR LATIMER ANALYSIS- BEGIN
WITH ANY OTHER WITNESSES HERE
IN THE GALLERY SAYING NONE I
SEE NOBODY IN ROOM ONE TWELVE-
MODERATOR- KEEP MOVED OUT TO
THE WITNESSES WAITING TO
TESTIFY. VIA THE
TELECONFERENCING SERVICE CAN
YOU CHECK THE LINES PLEASE. YES
THANK YOU AND THEY GENERALLY
ARE WITNESS ON TODAY'S. FIVE
EIGHTY ONE ZERO SEVEN THE PRESS
ONE THERE WHAT. AND CURRENTLY I
ONE MOMENT PLEASE. JUST ANOTHER.
WHEN WE GO TO ONE FORTY PLEASE
GO AHEAD. YOUR COMMITTEE
MEMBERS GOOD MORNING IT'S
MICHAEL SKIP ON BEHALF OF
ALCOHOL JUSTICE IN THE
CALIFORNIA ALCOHOL POLICY
ALLIANCE- WE ARE OPPOSED TO
THIS BILL THANK YOU. THANK YOU
OPERATOR- MODERATOR CAN WE SEE
IF THERE'S ANYBODY AND SUPPORT.
ON THE PHONE LINES PLEASE. AND
EACH OF YOUR SUPPORT PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME. AT
THIS TIME STRIPPERS AND NOBODY
ANSWERED OKAY- THERE'S NO IS
THERE ANY OPPOSITION HERE IN
THE GALLERY SCENE HAT I'D SEEN
THAT AND WANT TO- MR SKIFF YOUR-
DULY KNOW. AS OPPOSITION. TO
THIS BILL- IS THERE ANY OTHER
WITNESSES. OPPOSING A. B. TEN
SEVENTY. MODERNIZE YOUR FARE
THAN POP YES LATE JOE IF YOU
ARE AN OPPOSITION AB TEN
SEVENTY THAT'S ONE ZERO AT THIS
TIME. WE. MISTER CHAIRPERSON WE
HAVE NO ONE. I THINK I HEARD
YOU SAY NO. THAT'S CORRECT YES
THE CORRECT. THAT'S CORRECT YEP
MUCH BETTER THANK YOU-
MODERATOR SO BRING BACK- TO THE
MEMBERS HAVING HEARD FROM THE
OPPOSITION A OF THE SUPPORT- WE
HAVE CENTER JONES THANK YOU
THANK YOU MR CHURCH HAD A QUICK
QUESTION EITHER FOR THE AUTHOR
FOR THE- WITNESS IN SUPPORT I
NOTICED IT IN AND MOST OF MY
WRITE UP IT'S SAYING THAT IT'S
ALLOWING MANUFACTURERS. TO GIVE
THE UMBRELLAS THIS IS ALSO
APPLY TO DISTRIBUTORS OR
DISTRIBUTORS ALREADY ALLOWED TO
DO THAT OR- DISTRIBUTORS CAN BE
CAN CONTINUE TO BE PROHIBITED I
JUST WAS ONE IN WHICH TRIGGERS
ARE ON THIS. A LITTLE BIT
MISLED OR ANSWER QUESTIONS. I
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN- TO THE
CAUSE THE QUESTION OF THE
QUESTION FROM SENATOR ON THE
BILL IS LIMITED TO THE
AUTHORITY FOR MANUFACTURERS TO
PROVIDE THESE- IN CONVERSATIONS
WITH THE DISTRIBUTORS WE ADDED
LANGUAGE TO MAKE IT CLEAR THAT
THE DISTRIBUTORS CANNOT. BE
PASSED TO COST SHARE WITH THE
MANUFACTURERS. THAT WAS AT
THEIR REQUEST THEY DON'T WANT
TO BE PART OF OUR- ABILITY TO
SUPPORT THESE RESTAURANTS. THEY
WORK WITH THEM INDEPENDENTLY
BUT THEY DID NOT WANT TO BE
PART OF THIS BILL- THEY DO NOT
HAVE THE AUTHORITY TO DO IT
ABSENT A STATUTE COMING BEFORE
THE LEGISLATURE AS WELL. BUT
WE'VE WORKED WITH THEM TO MAKE
SURE THAT THEY DID NOT BEAR ANY
OF OUR COSTS. OKAY SO OF IT SO
FAST AND CORRECTLY-
DISTRIBUTORS. UNDER CURRENT LAW
CANNOT- DON'T GIVE AWAY THESE-
ROLLERS OR OTHER ITEMS IN THIS
BILL DOES NOT CHANGE THAT
CORRECT OKAY THANK YOU I'M
SUPPORTIVE IN- WOULD MOVE THE
BILL. THAT OUR BORDERS. I JUST
WANT TO COMMEND MY FRIEND A
SETTLEMENT COOPER ON THE WORK
HE'S DOING TO- HELP THE
RESTAURANT INDUSTRY. HAPPY TO
SUPPORT. GABRIEL'S CENTER
GLAZER MAKING SURE THAT I
WANTED TO JUST TO ADD MY VOICE
TO SUPPORT IT'S AN EIGHTEEN
HUNDRED DOLLAR BENEFIT TO AN
INDUSTRY OR A RESTAURANT THAT
IS CERTAINLY STRUGGLED
THROUGHOUT OUR STATE AND IT
ALSO IS LIMITED IN TERMS OF ITS
APPLICABILITY- WITH THE SUNSET
AND WITH THAT I'M HAPPY TO
SUPPORT IT TODAY. TRAFFIC
ANYBODY ELSE CENTER JONES. THAT
THINKERS ARE I JUSTWANT TO
CLARIFY THAT MY SUPPORT OF THE-BILL WAS REGARDLESS OF THE
ANSWER THE QUESTION THAT WAS
MORE OF A CURIOSITY. IF THE-
YOU KNOW THE DISTRIBUTORS WANT
TO COME BACK AND- ASK FOR THE
SAME THING I THINK I'D BE
SUPPORTIVE OF THAT AS WELL SO-
THANK YOU I JUST WANT TO
THANK YOU MR CHAIR BUT I FEEL
LIKE EVERYONE HAS SHARED. YOU
KNOW MY THOUGHTS AND CONCERNS
THAT I NAILED TO ME WAS
IMPORTANT THEREIS A SUN SAID
AND- YOU KNOW I THINK IN A TIME
OR RESTAURANTS AND- AND NEED
OUR HELP I THINK IT'S
APPROPRIATE AS WELL SO. I WILL
ALSO BE SUPPORTING THE BILL
THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT TERRIFIC-
THE BILL IS A GOOD MOVE BITES
OF. CENTER COOPER.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER COOPER SKEWS ME
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL. OKAY
THE BILLS WERE MOVED BY SENATOR
JONES THE MOTIONS DO PASTOR
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
DOT YEAH HI DOT HI NELSON
NIELSEN HI ALAN ARCHULETA
ARCHULETA I'D BECKER BARGES
ORDERS HI BRADFORD GLAZER HI
PLEASE R. I. WESO. JONES JONES
HI KEN LONGER MELENDEZ
MELINDA'S I PUT INTO YOU KNOW.
HI ACCORDING TO YOU KNOW I.
RUBIO HI RUBIO I WILL. BILL'S
GOT NINE VOTES WILL PLACE THE
BILL ON CALL. IT WILL NOW MOVE
ON TO A FILE ITEM NUMBER. WHAT
NUMBER IS THAT MR. FOLLOW THE
NUMBER- NINE. AB ELEVEN SEVENTY
THREE SEVEN MEMBER COOPER
YOU'RE STILL ALIVE THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN VERS A B. ELEVEN
SEVENTY THREE WILL LEVEL
THOROUGHBRED RACING
ASSOCIATIONS TO INCREASE BY TWO
FROM SIX TO EIGHT THE NUMBER OF
NON THOROUGHBRED ARABIAN RACES
PER CALENDAR YEAR. THIS
INCREASE IS ALLOWED AS LONG AS
IT DOESN'T CONFLICT WITH THE
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA FAIR
CIRCUIT WHICH ALSO PUTS ON
ARABIAN RACES IN ADDITIONAL
RACES MUST BE APPROVED BY THE
C. H. R. B. IN THE THOROUGHBRED
OWNERS OF CALIFORNIA. IS THIS
THE TWO RACES WILL PROVIDE
MARKETING OPPORTUNITIES TO
SHOWCASE AND PROMOTE ARABIAN
RACING CALIFORNIA'S RACE TRACKS
THE BILL ALSO ADDRESSES THE
PROCESS FOR DETERMINING
COMPENSATION PAID TO LESSONS
ACCOUNT WAGERING SERVICE
PROVIDERS FOR PROCESSING WAGERS.
ON LIVE HORSE RACES. THE
SEVENTH WOULD CLARIFY THAT
DECISION OF THE ARBITRATOR HAS
NOT AND BINDING. BUT RATHER
SUNDAY TO JUST REVIEW. HELLO AT
EASTON FOR THE- TO PLY IN
REACHING HIS OR HER DECISION.
THE BILL ALSO MODIFY THE RAY OF
COPPER. TO PAID BY THE COMPANY
PART AWAY. DURING ARBOR. IN ANY
SUBSEQUENT COURT CHALLENGES
THAT SUCH INTERNAL RATE OF
COMPENSATION IS FAIR TO ALL
PARTIES. THERE'S NO OPPOSITION
TO THE BILL DOES NOT CONSENT TO
LAST NIGHT. WITH HER CHILDREN
L. DETERMINATE MIGHT HAVE
PROBLEMS WITH THE BILL. DESPITE
THE RECORD SIR AND I WORK WITH
THEM TO TRY AND ADDRESS THEIR
CONCERNS. PUBLICLY TODAY'S IS
WITNESS SCOTT DAUGHERTY SAID IT
WAS PRESIDENT SENATOR IN GOLDEN
GATE FIELDS. IN THE GRAVE OF.
OLLIE THOROUGHBRED OWNERS OF
CALIFORNIA. MR DAUGHERTY ARE
YOU THERE. YES I AM PLEASE
PROCEED- THANK YOU MY NAME IS
SCOTT TO RUDY I'M SENIOR VICE
PRESIDENT OF SANITY TO RACE
TRACK AND GOLDEN GATE FIELDS
RACE TRACK IN WHICH WE SUPPORT
AT ELEVEN SEVENTY THREE I WANT
TO POINT OUT TO THE COMMITTEE
THIS BILL DOES NOT REALLY
CHANGE EXISTING EIGHTY W. LAW.
BUT RATHER FIXES A POTENTIAL
CONSTITUTIONAL FLOCKING
EXISTING LINE OKAY- MY
COLLEAGUE MISTER APP YOU'LL
YOU'LL SPEAK A LITTLE BIT MORE
TO THAT I JUST WANTED TO POINT
OUT THAT. YEAH THERE ARE THREE
PARTIES WITH AN ECONOMIC
INTEREST IN AN ONLINE WAGER ON
HORSE RACING. AN EXISTING LAWN
CHAIRS OUT A DELICATE BALANCE
IF THE ECONOMIC INTEREST OF
THOSE THREE PARTIES. IT DOES
THAT THROUGH A PROVISION THAT
SAYS. ONLY TWO OF THE THREE
PARTIES NEED TO SIGN AN
AGREEMENT IN ORDER FOR THOSE
WAGERING ACTIVITY TO TAKE
PLACE. AND THE BALANCE COMES
FROM THE FACT THAT THE THIRD
PARTY WHICH IS NOT A PARTY TO
THE AGREEMENT. HAS A RIGHT TO
INITIATE AN ARBITRATION
PROCESS- IF IT BELIEVES THE
AGREEMENT NOT FAIR- THIS
ARBITRATION PROCESS THIS
BALANCING ACT WE AS AN INDUSTRY
HAVE LIVED UNDER FOR THE LAST
ROUGHLY SIXTEEN YEARS AND ITS
SERVICE WELL- THE ACTIVITIES
GROWN IT'S PROVIDED- ECONOMIC-
USE YOUR BENEFITS ALL PARTIES
AND IT'S JUST BEEN A- A FAIR
PROCESS ONLY THIS PAST
DECEMBER. IT IN OUT OF STATE
EIGHTY W. COMPANY- RAISED THE
POSSIBILITY THAT EXISTING
STATUTE. I WOULD NOT PASS
CONSTITUTIONAL MUSTER IN THERE
FOR THAT PARTY THAT OUT OF
STATE PARTY REFUSED TO
PARTICIPATE IN. THIS PROCESS
SO- WE'RE HERE TO SERVE. A. B.
SEVENTY THREE- BECAUSE WE
BELIEVE THE BALANCING ACT
THAT'S BEEN CARRIED OUT BY THE
STATUTE FOR THE LAST FIFTEEN
YEARS HAS WORKED WELL. NO WE
THINK THAT BALANCING ACT SHOULD
CONTINUE AND- THEREFORE WE
SUPPORT A P. ELEVEN SEVENTY
THREE THANK YOU THANK YOU MR
DIRITTI- MISTER HAPPILY. ARE
YOU ON THE LINE. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR- MEMBER OF
COMMITTEES GREG HAVE YOU ALL IN
PRESIDENT OF SURVEILLANCE
CALIFORNIA. AS MR JURY SAID
EIGHTY WHR AND GIVES US A
DRIVING FORCE IN HORSE RACING
IN CALIFORNIA RIGHT NOW HOUSE
ROUGHLY SEVENTY FIVE PERCENT.
OF ALL WAIT DURING THIS PROJECT
TO BE ONE POINT TWO BILLION
DOLLARS THIS YEAR. ON THE
EXISTING STATUTES SECTION
NINETEEN SIX OH HORROR OF THE
COVER GRADY WH RIGHT. AT A
PROVISION IN THERE THAT SAID
THAT IF. THE HORSEMEN ORDER
TRACK I HAD A ISSUE WITH A FEE
AGREEMENT THAT THE OTHER PARTY
REACH WITH AN OUT OF STATE
PROPERTY OR IN STATE COMPANIES
IT WOULD GO TO A STREAMLINED
ARBITRATION. THAT SHOULD OCCUR
WITHIN SIXTY MINUTES FROM SIXTY
DAYS FROM THE DATE YOU
ARBITRATIONS FILED. R. MY
ORGANIZATION THE TOC WE USE
THIS PROVISION THIS YEAR TO
SEEK ARBITRATION WITH CHURCHILL
THAT THEY WERE TAKING WAS TOO
HIGH GIVEN THE ECONOMICS OF US
CALL IT. AND RATHER THAN
CONSENT OR DISTRIBUTORS AND THE
SUIT THE TOC IN FEDERAL COURT
CLAIMING THAT THE LEGISLATION
PASSED BY. CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATURE WAS DEFECTIVE
BECAUSE TWO BASIC REASONS IT
DID NOT PROVIDE FOR JUDICIAL
REVIEW OF THE ARBITRATOR'S
DECISION AND IT DID NOT SET A
STANDARD FOR THE ARBITRATOR TO
APPLY- WE THEN WENT TO A
REGULAR THE SUITS ARE BE. WHO
IN TURN BROUGHT IN THE
CALIFORNIA ATTORNEY GENERAL WHO
SAID WE THINK THAT THE
LEGISLATION. NEEDS TO HAVE
JUDICIAL REVIEW IN ORDER. TO BE
CONSTANTLY VALUE GOING FORWARD
BUT WITH THE HELP OF MISTER
COOPER- WE WERE ABLE TO PUT
TOGETHER THIS LEGISLATION WHICH
DIRECTLY ADDRESSES THOSE
CONCERNS. AND AS MR RUDY SAID
DOES NOT SUBSTANTIVELY CHANGE
BANKING LEGISLATION. SIMPLY
PROVIDES FOR JUDICIAL REVIEW.
AS THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR
CHAIRMAN THANK GOODNESS YOU
HAVE THE- THE- ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN THE GALLERY.
PLEASE PROCEED THE GERMAN
REMEMBER SCOTT WEDGE ON BEHALF
OF LOS ANGELES TURF CLUB. THANK.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR JUST
AS ON BEHALF OF THE
THOROUGHBRED OWNERS OF
CALIFORNIA AND DEL MAR
pTHANK YOU THANK YOU ANY
WITNESSES IN ROOM ONE TWELVE
SEE NONE- THANK YOU NOW WE'LL
MOVE ON TO WITNESSES WAITING TO
TESTIFY VIA THE TELECONFERENCE
OR CHRIS MODERATOR COULD YOU
PLEASE PROMPT INDIVIDUALS
WAITING TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
OF SB ELEVEN. SEVENTY THREE.
THANK YOU AND LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WANT TO
WITNESS OR EIGHTY ONE ONE SEVEN
THREE PLEASE PRESS ONE AND ZERO
AT THIS TIME. ONCE AGAIN THAT'S
ONE ZERO IN SUPPORT AB. ONE ONE
SEVEN THREE. AT THIS TIME I
HAVE NO WARNING Q. I THANK YOU-
NOW HAVING HEARD FROM ALL THE
SUPPORTERS WILL NOW FOLLOW THE
SAME PROCESS HERE FROM ANY
OPPOSITION I BELIEVE WE HAVE
JOHN NORWOOD ON BEHALF OF
CHURCHILL DOWNS HERE THE
GALLERY MISTER NORWOOD WELCOME.
YES MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
JOHN NORWOOD ON BEHALF OF
CHURCHILL DOWNS AND IT'S EIGHTY
W. PROVIDER TRANSPIRES DOT COM
I WANT TO BE CLEAR NOT HERE IN
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL- AS YOU
HEARD THE GENESIS OF THIS
LANGUAGE- AROSE AS A RESULT OF
A DISPUTE BETWEEN OUR CLIENT
AND I. HOST TRACK- THAT DISPUTE
WAS SETTLED- PRIVATELY- DUE TO
THE DIVIDED NATURE OF THIS LAST
WEEKEND OF THE FACT THAT THESE
AMENDMENTS DIDN'T COME INTO
PLAY UNTIL LATE LAST WEEK WE'VE
ONLY HAD A LIMITED OPPORTUNITY
TO LOOK AT THESE I THINK THAT-
IF THE LANGUAGE GOES BEYOND
THE- DEFECTS IDENTIFIED BY THE
G. BY THE AG AND THE
ARBITRATION AGREEMENT WE- MIGHT
HAVE SOME ISSUES BUT- RIGHT NOW
THAT'S- UNCLEAR WE HAVE. GREAT
RESPECT FOR THE AUTHOR AND- I'M
HAPPY TO WORK WITH HIM- IN HIS
SPONSORS AND IF WE HAVE ANY
CONCERNS WERE ALL FULL THAT WE
CAN WORK THEM OUT- AMICALE-
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU
MR NOR. ARE THERE ANY OTHER
WITNESSES NONE OTHER IN THE IN
THE- GALLERY ROOM ONE TWELVE
SEEING NINE- NOW WE'LL MOVE ON
TO WITNESSES- MODERATOR WAITING
TO TESTIFY VIA TELECONFERENCE
OR DOES. IT ALL IN OPPOSITION.
TO ELEVEN SEVENTY THREE. THANK
YOU AND ARE YOU ARE IN
OPPOSITION TO AB ONE ONE SEVEN
THREE PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. ONE CAN
OPPOSITION AB ONE ONE SEVEN
THREE PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT
THIS TIME. MISTER CHAIR PERSON
WE HAVE KNOWN IN Q. OKAY
FANTASTIC THANKS TO ALL OUR
SUPPORT OPPOSITION WITNESSES
WILL NOW BRING THE DISCUSSION
BACK TO OUR MEMBERS. ANYBODY
WISHING TO COMMENT ON THIS. AS
IT MAY HAVE A MOTION. SENATOR
BOARD JUST- THE MOTION BY YOU
ASSEMBLYMEMBER COOPER EXCUSE ME
I'M SORRY SIR SOMEBODY SENATOR
RUBIO. THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT I
JUST WANT TO COMMENT THAT THE
AUTHOR FOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD I KNOW THAT THERE IS
CONCERNS EXPRESS HOME BUT I DO
UNDERSTAND THAT THE AUTHOR HAS
TAKEN A MINUTE AND IS WILLING
TO CONTINUE TO WORK ON THIS AND
SOUL I ALSO WANT TO SUPPORT THE
BILL THANK YOU. THANK YOU
SENATOR RUBIO- SOME REMEMBER
COOPER WOULD LIKE CLOSE
RESPECTFULLY ESTHER I WILL
THANK YOU SEMI MEMBER- THE
BILL'S BEEN MOVED BY CENTER
BOARD JUST THE MOTION IS TO
PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. DOT I THOUGHT I'D
NIELSEN ON NELSON ALL RIGHT
ALAN. OKAY ALLEN HI ARCHULETA
ARCHULETA I'D BECKER FORGES ON
BORDERS BRADFORD BLAZER. WHERE
I. WESO JONES. CAN LONGER
MILLIS I LEARNED THIS I PUT
INTO NOW NINE POINT YOU KNOW I
RUBIO RUBIO I WILL. BILL AS
NINE VOTES WILL PLACE THE BILL
ON CALL NOW MOVED I'LL FILE
NUMBER FOURTEEN A. B. ELEVEN OH
THREE. ASSEMBLY MEMBER DOLLY
HERE SHE SURE IS. THE MORNING
ASSEMBLYMEMBER DOLLY WELCOME.
YEAH. GOOD MORNING KAREN
MEMBERS AB ELEVEN OH THREE
CREATES A STANDARDIZED TRAINING
AND FRAMEWORK FOR A LIVESTOCK
PASS PROGRAM ALLOWING RANCHERS
TO ACCESS OUR PROPERTY
EMERGENCY TO SAVE THE LIVESTOCK
TODAY MARKS THE FIFTH COMMITTEE
HEARING FOR THIS BILL
THROUGHOUT THOSE FIVE HEARINGS
I'VE WORKED EXTENSIVELY WITH
STAKEHOLDERS TO CLARIFY THE
BILL INCLUDING LABOR LAW
ENFORCEMENT THE CALIFORNIA.
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF WINE
GRAPE GROWERS WE'VE NEGOTIATED
LANGUAGE TO LIMIT THE SCOPE OF
THE DELTA LIVESTOCK PASS WHICH
WILL REMOVE CONCERNS FROM THE
WINE GRAPE GROWERS. AND INTENT
I INTEND TO TAKE THESE MOMENTS
OF THE NEXT COMMITTEE AND ALL
STAKEHOLDERS HAVE BEEN
CONSULTED AND HAVE APPROVED THE
PROPOSED CHANGE TO LIMIT THIS
BILL TO LIVESTOCK PASS. THE
LIVESTOCK PASS PROGRAM ENABLES
EMERGENCY RESPONDERS TO PROVIDE
RANCHERS ACCESS TO THE PROPERTY
TO TREAT AND RESCUE ANIMALS AND
PROVIDE SUPPORT TO EMERGENCY
PURCHASE OF PERSONNEL SUCH AS
IDENTIFYING ACCESS ROADS AND
WATER SOURCES. THESE PROGRAMS
ARE NIGHT NOT WIDESPREAD IN
CALIFORNIA IN PART BECAUSE OF
THE SIGNIFICANT EFFORT
REQUIRED. FOR A COUNTY TO
IMPLEMENT THE PROGRAM WITH NO
STANDARDIZED PROGRAMMER
TRAINING COUNTIES MUST DEVELOP
THEIR OWN INDIVIDUAL BASIS
WHICH IS TIME CONSUMING AND
COSTLY. A. B. ELEVEN OH THREE
IS THE SOLUTION AND REQUIRE THE
STATE FIRE MARSHAL TO ESTABLISH
A STATEWIDE FRAMEWORK AND
TRAINING FOR LIVESTOCK PASS
PROGRAM COVERING FIRE BEHAVIOR
AND EMERGENCY RESPONSE. THE
LIFE SCIENCE PASS HOLDER WILL
BE ALLOWED TO ACCESS THE
MURDERS HE RESPONSE AREAS WITH
THE CONSENT OF LAW ENFORCEMENT
TO SAY THEIR LIVESTOCK IN THE
EVENT OF A FIRE OR. OTHER
EMERGENCY SITUATION. TODAY WITH
ME TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL INTERNEES TURNOUT AT.
THE BATTALION CHIEF FOR SANTA
BARBARA COUNTY SHERIFF- COUNTY
FIRE. AND ON THE LIN JUST TO
ANSWER ANY TECHNICAL QUESTIONS
OF THE COMMITTEE IS JASON
BRYANT ON BEHALF OF THE
SPONSORS THE CALIFORNIA.
CATTLEMEN'S ASSOCIATION. THANK
YOU SEMI MEMBER- MOVIES NOW
MOVING ON TO- TEST TESTIMONY OF
SUPPORT MR STORE DATA. YOU'RE
ON THE LINE YOU MAY BEGIN. GOOD
MORNING MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF
THE COMMUNICATION LINE. I CAN
HEAR YOU FINE. OKAY PERFECT
GOOD MORNING NAME AT THE STORE
NOW ONE OF THE CHANGES WITHIN
OUR COUNTY FIRE DEPARTMENT I AM
pSERVICE BUT I'M ALSO A CATTLE
PRODUCER AND THE CHAIR OF THE
CALIFORNIA CATTLEMEN'S
ASSOCIATION FIRE SUBCOMMITTEE.
WHERE EVERYBODY'S HAPPY AND
HELP DEVELOP CEMETERY AND HAVE
GRAHAM DURING WILDFIRES
RANCHERS ARE OFTEN UNABLE TO
BYPASS ROAD CLOSURES PROVIDE
DENTAL CARE- EVACUATION JUNIOR
LIVESTOCK THE RESULTS ARE
DEVASTATING MANY LIVESTOCK OR
KILLED OR INJURED IN BLATANT
EACH YEAR AND RANCHERS ALL TOO
OFTEN PUT THEMSELVES AT RISK
REPEATING. EVACUATION ATTENDING
THEIR HERDS. SECOND STRING
RANCHERS SHAKE MY YET.
ENTRAPMENT OF INSPIRED ME YEAR
AND A MAKING ME OPERATES. IN
WHICH ALL THIS TRAINING ALLOWS
RANCHERS OR STAY SAFE AND
PANORAMA. MY THOUGHT PATTERNS
ARE ALSO VERY BENEFICIAL ABOUT
FIRE AND LAW ENFORCEMENT
PERSONNEL. THANKS LIVESTOCK
PASSES. IN OUR COUNTY RANCHERS
CONSISTENTLY ASSIST
FIREFIGHTERS MAY HELP US
IDENTIFY. FIRE ACCESS POINT
WATER SOURCES FIRE BREAKS I
DIDN'T FIND HAZARDOUS AREAS.
WHILE FIREFIGHTERS WORK AT
NINE. YEAH IN MY CRITIC IN TIME
AREA FIRE HISTORY. AND ALL ONLY
THREE CANADA MY PODCAST
PROGRAMS. IN A BAR IN THE-
WITHOUT A STATEWIDE SPRING
THOSE CAN EVEN REACH READ THE
WHEEL NEARLY EVERY COUNTY CAN
BENEFIT FROM A LIFE. RAM
UNFORTUNATELY MANY COUNTIES
LACK THE RESOURCES AND
EXPERTISE TO ESTABLISH A
LIVESTOCK ASPIRIN FROM SCRATCH
EIGHTY ONE OH THREE FACILITATES
COUNTY PRODUCTION OF LIVESTOCK
TRANSPORTERS BY SCAVENGING
STATEWIDE TRAINING PROGRAM
GETTING A CLEAR FINE OR WHAT
CIRCUMSTANCES MERGERS BONNER
SELLOUT. TRAINED ACTUALLY
RANGERS TO ACCEPT. CASH
PROGRAMS ONE ABLE BRANCHES OF
SIGNATURE THAT HOPEFULLY WILL
BE IN THE ANIMALS IN THEIR
CHARGE WITHOUT PUTTING
THEMSELVES IN HARM'S WAY. HE'S
ACT PASSED AROUND ALSO PROVIDE
A LEVEL OF ACCOUNTABILITY WE
HAVE NEVER HAD A PROBLEM
IDENTIFIED. INTO DO YOU LIVE IN
OUR GYM LOCATED ON AN ANSWER.
FOR ALL THESE REASONS YOU'RE
EITHER ON. EIGHT ELEVEN THREE.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU CHIEF
STORY- NEXT SPEAK IN. THANK BYE
IS JUST HERE FOR QUESTIONS OKAY
THANK YOU VERY MUCH APPRECIATE
THAT SOMEONE NEVER THOUGHT SO
NOW- MODERATOR WILL- CHECK
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE THROUGH
FOUR WITNESSES WAITING TO
TESTIFY. IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU ARE
A SIGN IN SUPPORT OF EIGHTY ONE
ONE ZERO THREE PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO AT THIS TIME. WE'RE GONNA
GO TO LINE NUMBER TWENTY THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
MILITARY MEMBERS THIS IS JASON
BRYANT ON BEHALF OF THE STATE
CATTLE RANCHING FAMILIES
REPRESENTED BY THE CALIFORNIA
CATTLEMEN'S ASSOCIATION AS THE
AUTHOR MENTIONED WOODWORK
THROUGHOUT THIS PROCESSOR
FURTHER CLARIFIED THE BILL'S
PROVISIONS. TO ENSURE THE
BILL'S PROVISIONS ONLY CREATE A
LIVESTOCK PASS PROGRAM FOR
RANGING FROM RISK MANAGERS AS
WELL AS CLARIFIED THAT THE BILL
DOES NOT SUPERSEDE EXISTING
PASS PROGRAMS CURRENTLY
ESTABLISHED AT THE COUNTY LEVEL
FOR OTHER AGRICULTURAL
ACTIVITIES OUTSIDE OF RANCHING
AND LIVESTOCK AND WORK SUPPORT
THE BILL THANK YOU DOCTOR THE
COMMITTEE STAFF AND- YOU MR
CHAIRMAN YOUR WORK- AND
THINKING ABOUT. THIS PLACE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU- IT. ANY
OTHER- CALLS ON THE LINE-
MODERATOR JUST YOUR NAME YES-
ORGANIZATION AND POSITION.
THANK YOU NEXT IN THE LINE
NUMBER TWENTY SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. YES THE MORNING SURE
MEMBERS FRIENDSHIP ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA CLIMATE
AGRICULTURE NETWORK SUPPORT
MAYBE ON A. THREE THE NEXT ONE
TO GO TO LINE NUMBER SEVENTY
SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. THIS IS
KATIE LITTLE WITH THE
CALIFORNIA FARM BUREAU
FEDERATION AND SUPPORT THIS
BILL. THE MAN NEXT TO A LINE
NUMBER SIXTY SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING SHARON
MEMBERS TIM SMOLDER WITH WINE
INSTITUTE- WANTED TO NOTE FOR
THE COMMITTEE THAT WITH THE
BILL BEING LIMITED TO A
LIVESTOCK PASS PROGRAM WE ARE
MOVING OUR PHYSICIAN FROM
SUPPORT TO NEUTRAL NO PROBLEM
WITH THE BILL JUST DOESN'T
AFFECT OUR INDUSTRY ANY LONGER.
THANK YOU. AND ONCE AGAIN THE
GERMAN IF YOUR SUPPORT OF A. B.
ONE ONE ZERO THREE PLEASE PRESS
ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME AND
MISTER CHAIRPERSON WE HAVE NO
ONE ELSE IN Q. THANK YOU
MODERATOR. I HAVEN'T HEARD FROM
ALL SUPPORTERS WILL NOW FOLLOW
THE SAME PROCESS AND HEAR FROM
OPPOSITION I BELIEVE MICHAEL
MILLER IS ON THE COAST LINE. AS
LEAD OPPOSITION MR MILLER. A
GOOD MORNING CERTAIN MEMBERS OF
THIS IS LIKE A WHAT THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF WHITE
PAPERS. ON I WANT TO THANK THE
AUTHOR OF THE TWO MAIN STAFF-
WORKING WITH THE SLOW LAST WEEK
ON. RESOLVING OUR CONCERNS. OR
CONCERNS ARE BASICALLY THAT
THE- ALL THE UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCE OF SUPERSEDING THE
EXISTING AG- PAST PROGRAMS AND
CONFLICTS AND- NAPA. MENDOCINO
OUR ACCOUNT AND OTHERS. AND
THAT WASN'T THE INTENT OF THE
BILL THAT WE- SHOULD HAVE A
LIMITING THE SCOPE OF THE BILL
TO. THE CATTLEMEN- CAL ISSUES
ARE RESOLVED THEIR ISSUE WITH
THE COULDN'T GET THOSE PASSES
IN THOSE COUNTIES AND- AND WITH
THAT OUR COMMITMENT TO- TO TAKE
THOSE IN THEM IT'S AN
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE. AT
THAT POINT WE WOULD- BUT FOR A
POSITION AND WE JUST WANT THANK
THE AUTHOR THINKS ME. STEP OVER
HERE WITH US VERY MUCH THANK
YOU. THANK YOU MISS MILLER. I'M
NOT SEEING ANY IN THE- I SEE NO
IN ROOM ONE TWELVE. MODERATOR
CAN WE CHECK FOR WITNESSES
WAITING TO TESTIFY VIA THE-
TELECONFERENCE ORBIS AFTER
PROMPTING THEM PLEASE. YES AND
IF YOU'RE IN A POSITION AT ONE
ONE ZERO THREE PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO TEST THIS TIME. ONCE AGAIN
IT OPPOSITION A. B. ONE ONE
ZERO THREE PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. MISTER
CHAIRPERSON I HAVE NO WARNING
QUEUE AT THIS TIME. OKAY SO-
THANK YOU TO ALL OUR SUPPORT
OPPOSITION WITNESSES- WE WILL
NOW- BRING THIS BACK TO- OUR
OUR MEMBERS HERE ANYBODY
WISHING TO DISCUSS THIS SENATOR
NIELSEN- MOVES THE BILL.
ANYBODY ELSE HAVE ANY QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS. SEEING NONE A
SEVEN MEMBER DOLLY BEFORE YOU
CLOSE I WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
THERE'S A COMMITMENT TO FIX
THIS ISSUE WITH THE OPPOSITION
IS THAT CORRECT YES WE HAVE ALL
THE AMENDMENTS DRAFTED AND
READY TO GO TO THE NEXT THREE
PERFECT THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
THAT- YOU MAY YOU MAY CLOSE TO
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR EITHER.
THANK YOU SO MUCH MEMBER DOLLY
WE HAVE- A MOTION BY SENATOR
NIELSEN THE MOTION IS TO PASS
TO APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
GOD HI DONNA HI NIELSEN ALL
RIGHT NIELSEN HI ALAN HI ALAN
HI ARCHULETA. ARCHULETA I'D
BETTER ALL RIGHT BACKER HI
GORGEOUS ON FOR JUST FIVE
BRADFORD BLAZER. LASER SIGHT
WESO JONES CATALOGUER MELENDEZ
MELENDEZ I POURED INTO NOW NINE
ACCORDING TO KNOW I. RUBIO.
RUBIO I WILL. AND IT'S TEN
VOTES WILL PLACE THE BILL ON
CALL THANK YOU. THANK YOU SOME
OF OUR DOLLARS. ARE WILL NOW
MOVE TO ITEM NUMBER FIFTEEN AB
ELEVEN TEN ASSEMBLYMEMBER
REAVIS. ARE YOU IN THE HOUSE.
SURE WE MADE A CALL. THE
THERE'S A THERE'S A LOT THAT.
YEAH.
GOOD MORNING MR REAVIS-
WE'RE ON FIE ITEM NUMBER
FIFTEEN AB ELEVEN TEN SEVEN
MEMBER REVIEWS YOU MAY BEGIN
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN- AND
SENATOR IS GREAT TO SEE
EVERYBODY THIS MORNING- AND
BEFORE WE BEGIN I'D LIKE TO
THANK THE COMMITTEE STAFF FOR
THEIR ENGAGEMENT- AND I WANT TO
NOTE THAT ALL THESE. ACCEPTING
THE PROPOSED AMENDMENT THAT
WAS- SUGGESTED IN THE BILL
ANALYSIS AND- THIS MORNING TO
PRESENT SOME OF BILL ONE ONE
ONE ZERO WHICH- PROPOSES TO
CREATE THE CALIFORNIA CLEAN
FLEET. A CELERY TO PROGRAM
WHICH WILL PROVIDE A SINGLE
POINT OF CONTACT WITHIN STATE
GOVERNMENT. TO HELP SMALL
JURISDICTIONS TO SMALLER LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS AND SCHOOL
DISTRICTS PURCHASE ZERO
EMISSION VEHICLES. UNLIKE
LARGER JURISDICTIONS LARGE
CITIES ARE SOME TRANSIT
DISTRICTS AND THE LIKE SMALLER
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS FREQUENTLY.
LACK THE STAFFING RESOURCES. TO
IDENTIFY AND PURSUE STATE
GRANTS. GET TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE AND PURSUE FINANCING
TOOLS NECESSARY TO PURCHASE
ZERO EMISSION VEHICLES
AFFORDABLY. CAN SO FOR EXAMPLE
A- LARGE CITY LIKE LA MIGHT BE
ABLE TO GET A BULK DISCOUNT
WHEN BUYING FIVE HUNDRED
ELECTRIC BUSES AT A TIME. BUT
THAT'S UNAVAILABLE IN A CITY
LIKE WATSONVILLE. PURCHASES TO.
SO ASSEMBLY BILL. ONE ONE ONE
ZERO WILL SOLVE THIS ISSUE BY
PROVIDING LOW COST FINANCING
OPTIONS. AND TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE AS WELL AS- ENSURING
THAT WE CONSOLIDATE PURCHASES
TO. LEVERAGE BOTH DISCOUNTS FOR
SMALLER LOCAL GOVERNMENTS AND
SCHOOL DISTRICTS. RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR A VOTE. AND WITH THIS
ON THE PHONE TO TESTIFY IS. HE
DAVID WEISS COFF WITH NEXT GEN
POLICY AND WITH THAT THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR. THANK YOU SEMI
MEMBER- MISTER WHITE'S COUGH- I
DO WANT TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL. THANK YOU MR CHAIR
AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS- MY NAME
IS DAVID WEISKOPF ATTACKS IN
CALIFORNIA ACTION WORKS FOR
PROGRESSIVE POLICY CHANGE TO
ADDRESS ENVIRONMENTAL SOCIAL
RACIAL AND ECONOMIC INEQUITIES
CALIFORNIA. I'D ALSO LIKE TO
THANK THE NUMBER IN THE
COMMITTEE MEMBER COMMITTEE
STAFF- BUT STILL- AS MYSTERY
THAT SAYS RESPONSE TO IT AND HE
SHARED BY MANY PUBLIC ENTITIES-
INCLUDING SCHOOLS IN RURAL
TRANSIT DISTRICTS AS LONG AS
HOW THESE. THESE ENTITIES AND
SEE THE POTENTIAL COST SAVINGS
AND HEALTH BENEFITS FROM
ADOPTING ZERO EMISSION
VEHICLES. BUT MANY LACK ACCESS
TO THE TYPE OF RESOURCES AND
STAFFING CAPACITY TO. FORWARD
WHAT IS THE RESPONSE TO THE
NEEDS OF BRINGING THE SAME KIND
OF TOOLS THAT ARE AVAILABLE TO
LARGER CITY AND COUNTY
GOVERNMENTS TO THE REST OF THE
STATE'S PUBLIC ENTITIES THERE
ARE THREE PRIMARY COMPONENTS OF
COURSE THE BILL CREATES AN
OMBUDSPERSON DOT THE STREET
OUTREACH TO THESE ENTITIES THAT
CAN BENEFIT FROM THE TYPE OF
ASSISTANCE WE'RE OFFERING HERE.
AND TO CONNECT THEM WITH
EXISTING STATE RESOURCES AS
WELL AS PEER LEARNING
OPPORTUNITIES FOR FOLKS WHO
HAVE ALREADY TAKEN STEPS TO
SOME AREAS ARE JUST BEGINNING
TO CONSIDER. THE SECOND IS
LEVERAGES COMBINED BUYING POWER
TO DRIVE DOWN. THE COST OF
VEHICLES WITH THE- MONEY UP
FRONT SIDE. AND TO PROVIDE
GREATER CERTAINTY TO EMERGING
MEDIUM AND HEAVY DUTY ZERO
EMISSION VEHICLE. STRUCTURES
FINALLY CREATE CHAPTER TWO NEED
TO MOBILIZE SIGNIFICANT PRIVATE
CAPITAL- NOT JUST STATE MONEY
AND STATE INCENTIVES THAT ARE
HELPING FOLKS TO TRANSITION
HERE. REALLY BRING IN PRIVATE
CAPITAL THAT MAY OTHERWISE STAY
ON THE SIDELINES OF THE
AVAILABLE- BY CREATING THIS
CENTRALIZED STATE PROCESS I
WOULD WANT. TO SPEND. THROUGH
THE URGENT NEED TO HELP SMALL
AND RURAL TOWNS IN SCHOOLS AND
TRANSFORM. TO SAVE MONEY WHILE
ALSO GAINING ACCESS TO CLEAN
VEHICLES FOR THIS REASON I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
BOATS. THANK YOU MR VICE COP
NOW LET'S BEGIN WITH ANY OTHER
WITNESSES. SEEN NONE OF THE
GALLERY NINE AM ONE TWELVE.
MODERATOR PLEASE CAN WE CHECK
THE LIGHTS AND- MOVE ON TO
THOSE WAITING TO TESTIFY. IN
SUPPORT OF E. B. ONE ONE ONE
ZERO. THANK YOU AND IF YOU ARE
PART OF AB ONE ONE A ONE ZERO
PLEASE PRESS ONE AND ZERO AT
THIS TIME. WHAT W. FOR SUPPORT
OF AB ONE ONE A ONE ZERO PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO ON YOUR
TOUCHTONE ALL. FOR YOUR LINE
NUMBER SIXTY THREE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING SURE
MEMBERS NOCTURNAL CALLING ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ELECTRIC TRANSPORTATION
COALITION IN SUPPORT. NEXT
RENEWAL LINE NUMBER SEVENTY
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. YEAH HI
MIKE ROBESON ON BEHALF OF THE
CALGARY MUNICIPAL UTILITIES
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT. NOW
YOUR LINE NUMBER FIFTY PLEASE
GO AHEAD. THERE ARE THERE WITH
THE CALIFORNIA CONSERVATION
VOTERS IN SUPPORT. AND ONCE
AGAIN IF YOU ARE IN SUPPORT OF
EIGHTY ONE ONE ONE ZERO PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME.
MISTER CHAIRPERSON WE HAVE NO
ONE ELSE IN Q. PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NOW WILL
MOVE ON TO WITNESSES WAITING TO
TESTIFY- IN OPPOSITION TO AB
ONE ONE- SEE NOBODY IN THE
GALLERY NOBODY IN ROOM ONE
TWELVE. MODERATOR IF YOU PLEASE
PROMPT INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO AB.
ELEVEN TEN. THANK YOU IF YOU
ARE AN OPPOSITION AB ONE ONE
ONE ZERO PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO
AT THIS TIME ONE CAN OPPOSITION
TO A P. ONE ONE ONE ZERO.
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO ON
YOUR TOUCH TONE PHONE. THE
MATURE PERSON I'VE KNOWN IN
QUEUE AT THIS TIME. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH- WILL NOT BRING THE
DISCUSSION BACK TO OUR MEMBER
CENTER ARCHULETA YES THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR AND I'D DO WOULD
LIKE TO ACKNOWLEDGE THE FACT
THAT- THE AUTHOR HAS BROUGHT
SOMETHING FORWARD IT IS VERY
VERY IMPORTANT OBVIOUSLY WHAT
WE'RE LOOKING TO THE FUTURE
ZERO EMISSION VEHICLES AND I
JUST LIKE TO ASK THE AUTHOR IF
YOU WOULD. ALSO INCLUDE THE
VERBIAGE OF FUEL CELL HYDROGEN
BECAUSE WE'RE TRYING TO TALK
ABOUT FLEETS SCHOOL BUSES TO
ARRIVE A GARBAGE TRUCKS MEDIUM
TO HEAVY DUTY VEHICLES AND
EQUIPMENT AND WE CAN'T DO THAT
IN THE FUTURE IF WE DON'T
INCLUDE PEOPLE SELL HYDROGEN SO
WE CAN'T DO AN ELECTRIC WE
CAN'T DO IT ALONE WITH ANY OF
THINGS BUT WE HAVE TO INCLUDE.
EVERYTHING THAT'S POSSIBLE AND
IF WE CAN INCLUDE FUEL CELL
HYDROGEN IN THE VERBIAGE I
WOULD APPRECIATE IT AND I
DEFINITELY SUPPORT THE BILL AND
I'D LIKE TO MOVE IT. PROCRIT
TIME. SUMMARY THIS WOULD LIKE
TO RESPOND MR J. YES I
APPRECIATE. THE COMMENTS
SUGGESTION THAT SOMETHING I'M
NOT OPPOSED TO AND SO BE HAPPY
TO WORK MY STAFF HAVE REACH OUT
TO YOUR OFFICE AND BE HAPPY TO.
INCLUDE THAT. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THE MEMORY OF THE CITY
OTHER MEMBERS WISHING TO.
ADDRESS THIS ISSUE WE HAVE- A
MOTION BY SENATOR ARCHULETA THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS A MANAGER
PREPARATIONS COMMITTEE SIX. THE
CENTER BOARD JUST. THANK YOU.
NORMALLY I THINK I'D BE A
LITTLE RESERVED ON. A STATE
PROGRAM- THIS KIND ONLY BECAUSE
I THINK- THERE HAS TO BE SOME
FILLERS AND- IN OTHER
COMPONENTS OF THE PACKAGE BUT I
THINK WHAT MAKES THIS DIFFERENT
IS THAT WHEN YOU ARE EXPECTING
LOCAL MUNICIPALITIES WORKED FOR
COUNTIES. TO BE ABLE TO
CONVERGE AND TRANSFORM THEIR
FLEET THEN THE STATE NEEDS TO
PLAY AN ACTIVE ROLE AND I THINK
THAT IS ONE OF THE THINGS THAT
MAKES THIS A BILL THAT IS WORTH
MOVING IS BECAUSE NOT ALWAYS
DOES THE STATE STEP IN- WITH
ITS MANDATES AND IN THIS
PARTICULAR CASE I THINK. THIS
IS THE FIRST STEP IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION- AND I'LL BE
SUPPORTING IT TODAY AND COMMEND
THE AUTHOR OF FOUR. THE WORK IS
DONE- YEAH IN THE SPACE THANKS.
THANK YOU EVERYBODY ELSE. OKAY
WE HAVE THE MOST MY CENTER ARTS
A LOT OF THE MOTION IS TO PASS
THE MANAGER APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL DONNA HI DONNA HI
NELSON I'LL STILL SEND HI ALAN
HI. ALAN HI ARCHULETA.
ARCHULETA I'D BETTER. ALL RIGHT
BECKER HI GORGEOUS. OUR BORDERS
HI BRADFORD. LASER EYE. LASER
EYE WESO JONES. CATALOGUER
MELENDEZ. FLORENTINO HI
ACCORDING TO KNOW I'D RUBIO.
RUBIO I WILL. BILL HAS NINE
VOTES- PLACE BILL A CALL. I
WILL MOVE ON TO FOLLOW NUMBER
EIGHTEEN EIGHTY B. FOURTEEN
SEVENTY ONE DECEMBER ASSEMBLY
MEMBER PHILIP COULD DO IT YOU
MAY BEGIN SIR. GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIR AND MEMBERS A. B.
FOURTEEN SEVENTY ONE IS AN
IMPORTANT BILL THAT ADVANCES
GEOGRAPHIC DIVERSITY IN
OPERATIONS OF THE CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC UTILITIES COMMISSION.
AND I WILL GUARANTEE PURPOSES
TENABLE INVESTMENTS FOR THE IN
ENERGY INFRASTRUCTURE THAT
MEETS THE NEEDS OF EVERY
COMMUNITY ACROSS OUR STATE.
SEPARATELY AB FOURTEEN SEVENTY
ONE WILL REQUIRE AT LEAST ONE
CPUC APPOINTEE TO RESIDE IN
EACH OF THE FOLLOWING AREAS.
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA CENTRAL
VALLEY IN SOUTH SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA. THIS IS SIMILAR TO
THE CURRENT REGIONAL
REQUIREMENTS FOR THE CALIFORNIA
ENERGY COMMISSION STATE WATER
RESOURCE CONTROL BOARD BOARD OF
EQUALIZATION AND THE CALIFORNIA
AIR RESOURCE BOARD. EIGHTY
FOURTEEN SEVENTY ONE WOMAN SURE
THE COMMISSION HAS FIRST HAND
EXPERIENCE WITH ALL REGIONS OF
CALIFORNIA. AND WITH FURTHER
GUARANTEE APPROPRIATE AND
SUSTAINABLE INVESTMENT FOR OUR
ENERGY INFRASTRUCTURE THAT
MEETS THE NEEDS OF EVERY
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY WITH ME
TODAY ON THE PHONE TO PROVIDE
TESTIMONY. IS BIG WARDROBE
INSULT AS INTERIM EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR FOR THE CALIFORNIA
PARTNERSHIP FOR THE SAN JOAQUIN
COUNTY VALLEY. MICHIGAN'S ALL
SEE ON THE LINE. YEAH PLEASE
PROCEED SIR. GOOD MORNING
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS MY NAME SO
EITHER ONE SILENCE ON THEINTERMIX ACTOR DIRECTOR AT THE
OFFICE OF COMMUNITY AND
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT AT PRESENT
STATE OF CALIFORNIA PARTNERSHIP
OF SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY. AP
FOURTEEN SEVENTY ONE IS AN
IMPORTANT BILL TO ENSURE THAT
CPUC CONSIDERS THE NEEDS OF THE
CENTRAL VALLEY AND OF EVERY
COMMUNITY ACROSS CALIFORNIA
JUST NOT JUST LOS ANGELES AND
THE BAY AREA. CPUC DECISIONS
AFFECT EVERY PERSON THROUGHOUT
THE STATE AND WE MUST ENSURE
THAT THE COMMUNITY. COMMISSION
HAS FIRST HAND EXPERIENCE WITH
ALL REGIONS OF CALIFORNIA. THE
CALIFORNIA PRINCIPLES AND CAN
VALLEY PROVIDES AN
ORGANIZATIONAL FRAMEWORK FOR
CONNECTING COLLABORATING AND
ADVOCATING TO IMPROVE ISSUES
IMPACTING THE QUALITY OF LIFE.
IN THE SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY. DUST
EQUITABLE REPRESENTATION OF A
COUNTRY'S CENTRAL REGION AT
STATE AND FEDERAL LEVEL IS VERY
IMPORTANT TO OUR MEMBERS
REPRESENTING PUBLIC PRIVATE
SECTORS. WHAT SIXTY TWO CITIES
ARE MORE THAN FOUR MILLION
RESIDENTS WILL CALL THANK YOU
VALLEY HOME IT IS IMPORTANT TO
NOTE. THAT IS STILL ONE OF
CALIFORNIA'S MOST CHALLENGERS
IN COMPARISON TO THE REST OF
THE STATE. PUBLICLY THE BAYLOR
AT LEAST ONCE IF YOU SEE A
POINT TO RESIDE IN EACH OF THE
FOLLOWING AREAS. NORTH OF
CALIFORNIA'S CENTRAL VALLEY AND
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA. ACHIEVING
REGIONAL REPRESENTATION WILL
PROVIDE DIVERSITY OF THOUGHT
THE MORE EXPENSIVE IT
ACKNOWLEDGE OF UTILITY AND
ENERGY EXPENSES. AND BRING TO
BEAR OUR DECISIONS AFFECT
COMPANIES ACROSS THE STATE. IN
THE LAST SIXTEEN YEARS CAN YOU
BELIEVE THAT NOT ONE SINGLE
COMMISSIONER. HAS BEEN
APPOINTED FROM SOUND CAN VALLEY
A RURAL TOWN OR LOW INCOME.
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITY IT IS
TIME THAT THE DECISIONS MAKERS
AT CPC TRULY UNDERSTANDS THE
NEEDS AND CHALLENGES OF THE
ENTIRE STATE. BY SHARING THE
COMMISSION HAS FIRST HAND
EXPERIENCE WITH ALL REGIONS OF
CALIFORNIA WE CAN FURTHER
GUARANTEE APPROPRIATE AND
SUSTAINABLE INVESTMENT. IN OUR
ENERGY INFRASTRUCTURE THAT
MEETS THE NEEDS OF OUR
ACCOMPLISHMENTS. I RESPECTFULLY
ASK. FOR AIBO. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU MR GET OFF NOW THERE'S
NOBODY ELSE IN THE GALLERY
NOBODY IN. ROOM. ONE TWELVE. IF
ANYBODY'S. WILL MOVE ON THE
LINE TO SUPPORT. FOURTEEN
SEVENTY ONE. YES AND LADIES
GENTLEMAN OF YOUR SUPPORT OF
ONE FOUR SEVEN ONE PLEASE PRESS
ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME. ONE CAN
SUPPORT OF AB ONE FORCE ONE
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS
TIME. ONE MOMENT PLEASE. WE
JUST ANOTHER MOMENT. PICTURE
PATIENTS TO ONE MORE MOMENT. AT
THIS TIME TO GET OVER THE LINE
NUMBER THIRTY FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING THIS IS
NIKOLINA MAN AT THE BENDIGO
CATHOLIC AND SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. IN ONE SECOND AGENCY
FOR YOUR IF YOU ARE IN SUPORT
OF A B. ONE FOUR SEVEN ONE
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS
TIME. MISTER CHAIRPERSON WE
HAVE NO ONE ELSE IN Q. PLEASE
GO AHEAD. THANK YOU HAVING
HEARD FROM ALL SPORTS WILL NOW
FOLLOW THE SAME PROCESS IN HERE
FROM THE OPPOSITION SEE NO ONE
IN THE GALLERY NO ONE IN ROOM
ONE TWELVE- OP MODERATOR COULD
YOU PLEASE- PROP WITNESSES
WAITING TO TESTIFY VIA THE
TELECONFERENCE OR- IT ISN'T AN
ADMINISTRATIVE. BUSH TO TAP THE
BAND OPPOSITION. FOR EIGHTY ONE
FOUR SEVEN ONE THIS PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND WE
HAVE NOTICED MANY PREPOSITION
AT THIS TIME. OKAY THANK YOU
WE'LL BRING DISCUSSION BACK TO
THE MEMBERS. ANY MEMBERS-
WISHING TO ADDRESS THE- ON THIS
ISSUE FOURTEEN SEVENTY ONE I'M
SURE SENATOR ALLEN OR BACK OR
DO YOU HAVE SOMETHING TO ADD TO
THE FOURTEEN SEVENTY ONE. OKAY
THANK YOU- WITH THAT WE DO I'M
SORRY SENATOR WILK. THANK YOU
MR CHAIR WHILE I FIND THIS
PROPOSAL A LITTLE BIT ON THE
PAROCHIAL SIDE I THINK I THINK
IT'S MUCH NEEDED YOU KNOW. THE
PC WAS ACTUALLY THE RAILROAD
COMMISSION WAS FORMED DARN
HIRAM JOHNSON'S ERA BACK IN
NINETEEN ELEVEN. I THINK IT'S A
PORTFOLIO IS WAY TOO BROAD. I
THINK IT'S WAY TOO INSULAR IN-
SAN FRANCISCO AND I DON'T THINK
THERE'S A DIVERSITY ON THE ON
THE BOARD SO. I DON'T THINK
THIS IS A FINAL STEP BUT I
THINK IT'S A GOOD FIRST STEP
AND I'M GOING TO BE IN SUPPORT
OF THE BILL TODAY THANK YOU.
WAS THAT A MOTION SENSOR SO
MOVED. THANK YOU ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS- SEEING
NINE WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE
SOME REMEMBER THE CHAIR MEMBERS
ARE RESPECTFULLY ASKS FOR A
NIGHT OUT THANK YOU BILL'S BEEN
MOVED BY SENATOR WELL THE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
DOT BY DOT I'D NELSON HIGH
NELSON HI ALAN. ALAN I
ARCHULETA. ARCHULETA ICEBREAKER.
BORJAS OXFORD GLAZER HI BLAZER
ALL RIGHT WHY SO. BY MYSELF HI
JONES CAN LONGER MELENDEZ BUT
LENDERS I POURED INTO NOW HI
ACCORDING TO YOU KNOW I. RUBIO.
RUBIO I WILL I WILL HI. THE
LAST TEN VOTES WILL PLACE A
BILL ON CALL. OKAY THIS IS A
FINAL ITEM. I BELIEVE OF TODAY%
AND I WOULD LIKE TO- MAKE SURE
THAT ALL THE MEMBERS- AND THEIR
STAFFS THAT ARE LISTENING-
WE'RE GONNA OPEN THE CALL AFTER
THIS BILL HE HAD- WE NEED TO-
MOVE ON AND ALLOW THE- CHAMBERS
TO BE USED FOR SOMETHING ELSE
SO WITH THAT. WE'LL MOVE TO OUR
NUMBER TWENTY FILE ITEM NUMBER
TWENTY TWO EIGHTY FOUR SIXTEEN
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHOLERA YOU MAY
BEGIN SIR. THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS- IT'S ALWAYS
GREAT TO BE ON THE RED CARPET I
JUST LEARNED SOMETHING ABOUT
CALIFORNIA HISTORY TESTING THE
DEAL WHEN I ENTERED THE
CHAMBERS. OF ACCEPTING THE
TWENTY MINUTES FOR THE GERMAN
BORDER FORCE IN THE BILL AND
MAKE IT ALMOST IDENTICAL TO MY
EIGHTY FIVE SEVENTY TWO FROM
TWENTY NINETEEN WHICH THIS
COMMITTEE GRATEFULLY- PAST. I
UNDERSTAND THE CONCERNS RAISED
ON THE ADDITIONAL BOREAL FOREST
AND AS THE ONLY CURRENT KTM ONE
LEGISLATURE ELECTED LEGISLATOR
ADAM AND MINIMIZES CONCERNS AND
APPRECIATE THE ABILITY TO MOVE
FORWARD WITH THE SCOPE OF
TROPICAL FORESTS. I DO HOPE WE
CONTINUE TO WORK ON THIS ISSUE
AND BUILD A MORE COMPREHENSIVE
POLICY IN THE FUTURE AS WELL
TROPICAL AND BOREAL FORESTS ARE
AMONG THE MOST CARBON DENSE
FORESTS ON EARTH. AND THEY PLAY
A VITAL ROLE IN STORING CARBON
AND PROVIDING HABITAT FOR
COUNTLESS ANIMAL AND PLANT
SPECIES. THE DESTRUCTION AND
DEGRADATION OF THESE FOUR IS
GOOD AND DISTINGUISH REAL SCALE
EXPLOITATION RESPONSIBLE FOR A
SIGNIFICANT PORTION OF GLOBAL
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS THAT
CONTRIBUTE TO CLIMATE CHANGE.
AS WELL AS WIDE RANGING IMPACTS
ON BIODIVERSITY AND HUMAN
RIGHTS ESPECIALLY WITH REGARD
TO PROTECT INDIGENOUS LIVES TO
WORSHIP AND GOVERNANCE OF THESE
LANDS. THAT IS AMENDED EIGHTY
FOUR SIXTEEN THE CALIFORNIA
DEFORESTATION PREDETERMINED ACT
WOULD REQUIRE ANY ENTITIES
CONTRACT WITH THE CITY
CALIFORNIA TO CERTIFY THAT
THEY'RE NOT CONTRIBUTING TO
TROPICAL DEFORESTATION DIRECTLY
OR THROUGH THEIR SUPPLY CHAINS.
THIRTY FOUR SIXTEEN IS MODELED
AFTER EXISTING SELECT FREE CODE
OF CONDUCT FOR STATE CONTRACTS
AND PROCUREMENT BEEN AGAINST
CHILD LABOR SO THIS LEGISLATION
IS NOT DISSIMILAR TO
PROCUREMENT POLICIES THE STATE
IS IMPLEMENTED IN PAST YEARS.
TO HELP ENSURE THAT CONTRACTORS
WE ARE WORKING WITH OR NOT
ENGAGING. IN HARMFUL PRACTICES.
ALSO IN ORDER PROMOTE PRACTICE.
THE PEOPLE SIXTEEN REQUIRE ON
THE PART GENERALS. TO DEVELOP A
DEFORESTED FREE CALL OF CONDUCT.
TO AVOID GUY TO COME. IN ORDER
TO. FOR US FOR COME ON. IN
THEIR SUPPLIES. AT THE FIFTH
LARGEST ECONOMY IN THE WORLD.
CALIFORNIA'S PURCHASING POWER
HAS SIGNIFICANT MARKET FORCE OF
THIS STILL EXTENDS OUR STATE'S.
ENVIRONMENT LEADERSHIP TO THE
PROTECTION OF TROPICAL FORESTS.
BY ADOPTING THIS PROCUREMENT
POLICY RICHER THE STATE IS NOT
IN IN IN BURTON. CONTRIBUTOR TO
THE DESTRUCTION AND DEGRADATION
OF TROPICAL FOREST. EIGHTY FOUR
SIXTEEN ENJOYS BROAD SUPPORT
FROM ENVIRONMENTAL POLICY AFTER
A WHILE I THOUGHT THE KIDS AND
COMMERCIAL BUSINESSES AND
INVESTORS. THAT SUPPORT
SUSTAINABLE PRACTICES. WITH ME
PROVIDE SUPPORTING TESTIMONY IS
GORE OF MODERN SENIOR FOR
SOMEONE. CAMPAIGNER FOR FRIENDS
OF THE EARTH AND NICK SOCKET
LEGISLATIVE ADVOCATE. FOR PEACE
FOR ANIMALS A. SOCIAL
COMPASSION IN LEGISLATION THANK
YOU. OKAY THE FIRST. ARE YOU ON
THE ON THE ON THE LINE. YES I
AM CAN YOU HEAR ME YES WE
CANCER PLEASE PROCEED. GOOD
MORNING MY NAME IS CARMEN DONE-
AND AS MENTIONED I SERVE AS THE
SENIOR FOR SAMANTHA CAMPAIGNER
FRIENDS OF THE EARTH WE ARE ONE
OF THE CO SPONSORS EIGHTY FOUR
WITH SIX. EVERY THREE DAYS THE
WORLD LOSES AN AREA OF FOREST
THE SIZE OF LOS ANGELES. WHAT
WE LOSE WHEN WE LOSE TROPICAL
FOREST WE LOSE COUNTLESS
SPECIES SO MUCH IN RHINOS BORN
INTO RANG A TANK GREAT APES
CARAMEL AND NUMEROUS MIGRATORY
BIRDS. INDIGENOUS PEOPLES LOSE
THEIR TRADITIONAL LANDS
CULTURES LANGUAGES AND IN MANY
CASES THEIR LIVES. AND WE
COLLECTIVELY LOSE OUR LAST BEST
CHANCE TO PREVENT AND MITIGATE
RUNAWAY CLIMATE CHAOS BECAUSE
ABOUT A QUARTER OF GREENHOUSE
GAS EMISSIONS. RESULT FROM
DEFORESTATION AND ASSOCIATED
LAND CONVERSION AND THE
DEGRADATION OF INTACT PRIMARY
FOREST. AT THE TWO THOUSAND
FIFTEEN YOU AND CLIMATE SUMMIT
GOVERNMENTS INDUSTRY AND CIVIL
SOCIETY CAME TOGETHER INSIDE
THE NEW YORK DECORATION FORCED
A COMMITMENT TO REDUCE GLOBAL
DEFORESTATION BY HALF BY TWENTY
TWENTY AND INDEED THE ENTIRELY
BY TWENTY THIRTY. CALIFORNIA AT
THE CLIMATE LEADERS SIGNED A
DECLARATION WHEN THE U. N.
ACEST PROGRESS IN TWENTY TWENTY
AND FOUND THAT NOT ONLY IN THE
WORLD MISSED ITS OWN TWENTY
TWENTY TARGET BUT INSTEAD
GLOBAL DEFORESTATION HAD
INCREASED BY OVER FORTY
PERCENT. WHY DEFORESTATION
INCREASING BECAUSE THERE IS NO
ECONOMIC OR REGULATORY
INCENTIVE TO STOP IT EIGHTY
FOUR ONE SIX CAN CHANGE THAT. A
RECENT DRAFT STUDY BY FRIENDS
OF THE EARTH REVEALED THAT
ROUGHLY ONE QUARTER OF
CALIFORNIA'S PUBLIC PURCHASING
IS LINKED TO THE RISK OF.
TROPICAL DEFORESTATION. SIX
HUNDRED MILLION IN PARKS THAT
COULD BE LEVERAGED TO STAY IN
THE WORLD CLASS ANY. BETTER
INSTEAD PAYING FOR THE- NOW
VIRTUALLY EVERY IN MY OR- IN
THE COUNTRY. THE BILL BECOME
LAW. NOTABLY INVESTMENT IS ALSO
BEHIND THE BILL A COALITION OF
INVESTORS THAT COLLECTIVELY
MANAGE ONE POINT SIX TRILLION
DOLLARS IN ASSETS HAVE MADE THE
CASE THAT EIGHTY FOUR ONE SIX
IS GOOD FOR BUSINESS. I WILL
CREATE A LEVEL PLAYING FIELD
FOR INDUSTRY CREATE MUCH NEEDED
TRANSPARENCY TO GLOBAL SUPPLY
CHAINS AND HOLD CORPORATIONS WE
STANDARD OF ENVIRONMENTAL
STEWARDSHIP. AND THE
MARKETPLACE INCREASINGLY DEMAND
AND WILL HELP PRESERVE OUR
WORLD FOR CHILDREN AND THEIR
CHILDREN AND THEIR CHILDREN. I
COLLECTOR PLEASE CAST YOUR VOTE
IN FAVOR OF A B. FALLEN SIX
CALIFORNIA DEFORESTATION. FREE
PROCUREMENT ACT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MR SACK ARE YOU ON
THE LINE. YES I AM HELLO CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY
NAME IS NICHOLAS ACTIVE
DIRECTOR OF LEGISLATIVE AFFAIRS
FOR SOCIAL COMPASSION IN
LEGISLATION PROUD BECAUSE- OF
THE BILL. LAST WEEK THE
CANADIAN NATIONAL TEMPERATURE
RECORD WAS BROKEN ON MONDAY
THEN AGAIN ON TUESDAY AND THEN
AGAIN ON WEDNESDAY WHEN
TEMPERATURES REACHED ONE
HUNDRED AND TWENTY ONE DEGREES.
SALEM OREGON HIT A HUNDRED
SEVENTEEN BEATING THE PREVIOUS
RECORD BY EIGHT DEGREES AND
CAUSING NEARLY ONE HUNDRED
DEATHS. JUNE TEMPERATURE
RECORDS WERE SET IN HELSINKI
BELARUS MOSCOW AND ACROSS
IBERIA AND ELSEWHERE. ARE YOU
GUYS LOOKING AT FASTER RATES
THAN EVEN CLIMATE CHANGE IS
ANTICIPATED. BUT WHAT UNITED
STATES AS IN THE MEGA DROUGHT
AS YOU ALL KNOW THE GOVERNOR
DECLARED A DROUGHT EMERGENCY IN
FORTY ONE OF OUR STATE'S FIFTY
EIGHT COUNTIES. EXTREME
TEMPERATURE FIRE AND WEATHER
EVENTS DOMINATE THE NEWS. THIS
IS NOT GOING TO END OUR STATE
IS DRYING OUT OUR PLAN IS ON
THE VERGE OF BURNING UP. THE
SITUATION IS DIRE IN CALIFORNIA
BALL PARTY SUPPORT ACTION YOUR
RECENT POLL CONDUCTED BY TOP
POSTER DATA ORBITAL SHOWED THAT
84% OF REGISTERED VOTERS IN THE
STATE ARE CONCERNED ABOUT OUR
STATE PROCUREMENT POLICIES
CONTRIBUTING TO DEFORESTATION.
THIS CONCERN TRANSLATE 81%
SUPPORTING THE POLICY OF THE
SPELL. EIGHTY FOUR ONE SIX AND
A SIMPLE BILL THAT WILL
DETERMINE WHETHER OUR STATE
GOVERNMENT BUYS PRODUCTS FROM
COMPANIES THAT ARE DOING THAT
BY OUR MOST IMPORTANT FOR.
INDIGENOUS PEOPLES AND ALL OF
US WHO WANT A HABITABLE PLANET
OR WILL OR STATE GOVERNMENT
TURNED A BLIND EYE BY
CONTINUING TO BUY PRODUCTS
PRODUCED BY COMPANIES STRIVING
THE DESTRUCTION OF THE STORES.
THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
NIGHT UP. THANK YOU MR SAQIB
THERE'S NO OTHER WITNESSES IN
THE GALLERY SCENE NOT IN ROOM.
ONE ONE TWO MODERATOR CAN YOU-
CHECK THE LAW CONFERENCE LINE
TO SEE IF THERE'S ANYBODY
WISHING TO TESTIFY. IN SUPPORT
OF SB. FOUR ONE SIX. LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN AND GOOD LUCK TO SHOW
SUPPORT FOR SP FOUR ONE SIX
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT
THIS TIME. ABOUT OUR FIRST LINE
NUMBER SEVENTY FIVE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. HI THIS IS JUDY MAN
COUP SO FOUNDER AND PRESIDENT
OF SOCIAL COMPASSION IN
LEGISLATION SPONSORED THE BILL
I AM CALLING AND SUPPORT ARE
OVER A HUNDRED AND FORTY GROUPS
THAT ARE IN SUPPORT. AND
THOUSANDS OF INDIVIDUALS THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. THANKS A LITTLE
ANXIOUS FEAR LIES OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. WITH THE CALIFORNIA
CONSERVATION VOTERS STRONG
SUPPORT. SEVENTY NINE HEARING
IMPLANTS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
ON BEHALF OF THE NATIONAL
ACTION COUNCIL IMPORT YEAH.
THANKS SIXTY ONE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING MR CHAIRMAN BURST LUCAS
FRERICHS ON BEHALF OF THE
NATURE CONSERVANCY IN SUPPORT
OF EIGHTY FOUR SIXTEEN THANK
YOU. THANK YOU TO YOUR LINE IS
OPEN IF I HAD. GOOD MORNING TEN
MEMBERS OF CONSTRAINING FELL ON
BEHALF OF ENVIRONMENTAL DEFENSE
FUND INTO COURT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR LINE IS NOW
OPEN. GOOD MORNING THIS IS JIM
LINDBERG ON BEHALF OF THE
FRIENDS COMMITTEE ON
LEGISLATION- CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. BY EIGHTY
SEVEN PLUS FIVE. I REMEMBER
THINKING ACCORDING TO CONDUCT
RESEARCH AT THE CENTRAL BILLING
SUPPORT. NINE EIGHTY ONE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
IN A GALLIARD FOR THREE FIFTY
SACRAMENTO AND SUPPORT. IN
ADDITIONAL LINE THANK YOU AT
THIS TIME. THANK YOU MODERATOR
HAVING HEARD FROM ALL THE
SUPPORTERS WE WILL NOW FOLLOW
THE SAME PROCESS HERE FOR MANY
OPPOSITION. WE WILL BEGIN WITH
MR AROUND US SARKAR- CONSUL
GENERAL OF CANADA WHO I BELIEVE
IS ON THE COAST LINE. CONSUL
GENERAL. MODERATOR IS THERE ARE.
THE CONSUL GENERAL ON THE LINE.
ONE MOMENT PLEASE LIE TRICKLING.
I DO NOT SEE THE NAME IN THE
OKAY. THANK YOU BYE MISTER
STEVE CRUZ ARE YOU ON THE LINE.
YES THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS SPEAKERS ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA BUILDING
INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION- I'M
ACTUALLY PROUD TO BE ABLE TO
REPORT THAT CDA ALONG WITH THE
OPPOSITION COALITION. WILL BE
REMOVING OUR OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL WITH WHAT WE UNDERSTAND
AGREE TO AMENDMENTS BETWEEN THE
CHAIR AND THE OFFICER THAT
WOULD REMOVE THE KOREA
PROVISIONS OF THE BILL- THE
GREATLY APPRECIATE THE WORK OF.
CHAIRMAN NEW CHAIRMAN DIED IN
DECEMBER CALL- LOOK FORWARD TO
LOOK WHAT THE OFTEN THE
COMMITTEE. AT THE BILL MOVES
FORWARD MAKE SURE- THAT UNITED.
HE WENT BACK ON CURRENT AND
THAT THERE IS USUALLY A LINE
WITH THE BUILDING- THE END OF.
THE WORK OF THE- YEAH THE CHAIR
THEY OFTEN. THANK THANK YOU
CRUZ JUST WHAT NOT A KNOWLEDGE
THAT CENTER CALLERS ASSEMBLY
KALRA HAS ALREADY AGREED TO
THOSE AMENDMENTS. THE OTHERS NO
OTHER WITNESSES- IN OPPOSITION
IN THE GALLERY OR IN ONE
TWELVE. MODERATOR CAN WE- SEE
IF THERE'S ANY WITH WITNESSES
WAITING TO TESTIFY. VIA THE
TELECONFERENCE ORVIS. SURE
LOOKS FINE OPPOSITION PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN THERE WAS THIS
TIME. REPORTER FIRST BY NUMBER
FORTY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE ON CAPPING
LYNCH AND I REPRESENT A
COALITION OF OPPONENTS WE WANT
TO THANK THE CHAIR AND VICE
CHAIR OF THE COMMITTEE
CONSULTANT. FOR THEIR DETAILED
WORK ON THIS MAJOR AND THANK
THE AUTHOR FOR TAKING PART IN A
LOT OF THE MAJOR WE BREAK WE
MAY REQUEST ADDITIONAL
CLARIFYING REFINING AMENDMENT
SAYS YEAH I AIN'T HAD
MENTIONED. HOWEVER WE'RE
PLEASED TO REMOVE OPPOSITION
FOR THE FOLLOWING ORGANIZATIONS
TODAY THE AMERICAN FOREST AND
PAPER ASSOCIATION THE AMERICAN
WOOD COUNCIL ASSOCIATED GENERAL
CONTRACTORS CALIFORNIA
MANUFACTURERS AND TECHNOLOGY
ASSOCIATION HELPED DEVELOP
BUSINESS BUILDING SOLUTIONS AND
WESTERN WOULD PRESERVERS
INSTITUTE. OTHERS ARE STILL
REVIEWING THE PROPOSED
AMENDMENTS AND I THINK YOU'LL
BE HEARING FROM THEM BEFORE THE
NEXT COMMITTEE THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. FOR YOUR WORK ON THIS
MAJOR. ABOUT ALIGN EIGHTY YEAR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO. MY NAME
IS ALLEN AND THE MEN FOR BE
SEEM TO OVER AND NOW SERVES AS
VICE TO YOUR HEART FORCE ISSUES.
HI THANK THE- AMENDMENTS AS
PROPOSED ARE SATISFACTORY TO US
THE REMOVE OIL FROM THE BILL.
AND I WANT TO SAY THAT- WE'RE
VERY PLEASED TO SEE THOSE
AMENDMENTS- WE EXPORT FIVE AND
FIFTY EIGHT MILLION DOLLARS FOR
THE STATE EVERY YEAR. AND WE
ALSO- SUPPORT THE STATE'S.
EFFORTS TO FIGHT WILDFIRES. WE
SENT TWENTY FOUR FOUR FOR
CONSISTING FIRES IN CATTLE.
THEN I THINK- WE CAN GUARANTEE
YOU THAT WE HAVE STRONG LAWS
REGULATIONS THE BC. TO PROTECT
THE FOREST TO ENSURE
SUSTAINABILITY PRACTICES
BARCLAYS OKAY. ACTIVELY
ENGAGING PEOPLE THANK YOU. YEAH
SEVERAL FIFTY EIGHT HE'S GOT.
OKAY GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS
IAN TODD- MONTERO'S
REPRESENTATIVE IN WASHINGTON DC
ONTARIO VERY MUCH APPRECIATES
THE OPENNESS TO OUR CONCERN
SHOWN BY BOTH THE CALIFORNIA
SENATE AND ASSEMBLY FOR REASONS
MENTIONED IN OUR LETTER OF
OPPOSITION ONTARIO POSES A B.
FOUR ONE SIX UNLESS AMENDED TO
REMOVE REFERENCE TO FOIL FOR US
THANK YOU FOR YOUR INFORMATION
IS THAT THE MMBER WAS TAKEN
PROPOSED AND TAKEN. THANK YOU.
OCTOBER ELEVENTH THIRTY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU-
TRISTEN PANEL READ ON BEHALF OF
THE GOVERNMENT OF ALBERTA IN
CANADA- ALSO WANT TO EXPRESS
APPRECIATION TO THE CHAIR
MEMBERS FOR YOU THE- THE
AMENDED BILL- WE WERE OPPOSED
TO THE BILL IN ITS ORIGINAL
FORM- BUT ARE VERY PLEASED WITH
THE CHANGES THAT WERE MADE.
THANK YOU. I LOOK. I NEED A
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. RIGHT
HELLO THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
HAVING ME TODAY TO SPEAK TO
EIGHTY FOUR ONE SIX MY NAME IS
RANA SARKAR AND THE CONSUL
GENERAL OF CANADA IN SAN
FRANCISCO I'D LIKE TO START BY
POINTING THE CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATURE'S CONCERN ABOUT
GLOBAL DEFORESTATION CANADA IS
COMMITTED TO KEEPING GLOBAL
FORCE HEALTHY PRODUCTIVE AND
THRIVING IN FACT IT SAID
DEBERRY COMMITMENT THAT MY
FRIEND ASSEMBLYMEMBER ASH KALRA
ALONG WITH SENATOR DOLE OUT OF
THIS COMMITTEE STAFF RECOGNIZED
IN WORKING ON THE AMENDMENTS TO
THE BILL THAT'S NOW BEFORE
YOUR- SENATORS CANADA WILL
CONTINUE TO RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE
BABY. FOUR ONE SIX IF THESE
AMENDMENTS ARE NOT AT THE
OFFICE WITHOUT THEM THE BILL
WOULD APPLY TO BOREAL FOREST
PRODUCTS WITHOUT DISTINGUISHING
BETWEEN COUNTRIES THAT HAVE-ROBUST SPORTS MANAGEMENT
PRACTICES LIKE CANADA AND THOSE
THAT DO NOT IN THIS FIGHT
AGAINST GLOBAL DEFORESTATION.
THIS IS A DISTINCTION THAT IS
CRITICAL. CANADA'S LEADER IN
FORCE. ARE FORCED UP 90% OF THE
GROUP OF WORLD'S FOREST COVER
BUT ONLY ACCOUNT FOR ONE THIRD
OF 1% OF GLOBAL DEFORESTATION.
IN CANADA 94% OF ALL FORESTS
ARE PUBLICLY OWNED AND MUST BE
REGENERATED WHEN HARVESTED IT'S
THE LAW. IF LEFT UNATTENDED
EIGHTY FOUR ONE SIX WOULD ALSO
IMPACT THE LONGSTANDING FOR
SECTOR SUPPLY CHAINS AND
COMMERCIAL LINKS THAT SUPPORT
JOBS AND ECONOMIC SECURITY
RIGHT HERE IN CALIFORNIA. AT A
TIME OF- ALREADY HIGHER LUMBER
COSTS THIS BILL WOULD ONLY
FURTHER RANGE PROCUREMENT
COSTS- ON PRODUCTS THAT ARE NOT
NOT CONTRIBUTING TO GLOBAL
DEFORESTATION. CANADA AND
CALIFORNIA ARE LONG TIME
FRIENDS AND SHARE MUCHIN
COMMON INCLUDING ROBUST LABOR
MACHINES AND SIMILAR
ENVIRONMENTAL POLICIES. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK THAT YOU ADOPT
THE AMENDMENTS. TO REMOVE
REFERENCE TO BOREAL AND INTACT
FORESTS AND IN DOING SO
DEMONSTRATE TO THE WORLD THE
CLOSE BONDS OF COMMONSENSE
FRIENDSHIP THAT BINDS CANADA
CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU. ACTS OF
VIOLENCE THIRTY SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING AT
MIDMORNING CHAIRS AND MEMBERS
MY NAME IS YOU KNOW- GOVERNMENT
UP TO BACK DOWN AGAIN BUT
CENTRAL MASS AND- I'M GLAD AND
APPRECIATE THE NEW FORM OF
EIGHTY FOUR SIXTEEN. AMENDED
WITH THE REMOVAL OF THE
REFERENCE OF MEMORIAL PARK I'M
NOT SURE IF YOU ALLOW ME I
WOULD LIKE TO REITERATE THAT
QUEBEC HAS A STRONG
RELATIONSHIP WITH CALIFORNIA.
WE ARE PROUD TO SAY- THAT WOULD
MORE THAN TWENTY FIVE YEAR WE
HAVE WE HAVE A LA COUNTY DURING
THE- SEASON. THE SCHOOL BOARD
THAT WERE PRO WERE ALSO. LIKE
TO STAY. OUR PURPOSE MANAGEMENT
IS GOT BY ENTERING. LIKE
RECOGNIZED PRINCIPLE OF SUPPORT
OF THE- TO MANAGE. FOR ALL
THESE REASONS AS A MATTER
ACTUALLY FROM- THAT AND THEN
CHIN- WE WILL OPPOSE IT COULD
NOT CHANGE ENGINE THREE NEAR
DEATH THE CHANGE UP AND UP TO.
SOMEWHERE OUR PEOPLE. K. WELL
THANK YOU- THERE MAY NOT BE ANY
OTHER SPEAKER I'VE GIVEN
TOUGHER TO OUR FRIENDS FROM
CANADA TO BE ABLE TO- JUST BY A
LITTLE LONGER THAN IS
CUSTOMARY. ALL OF THIS BUT IF
WE HAVE ANY OTHER- WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOU TO JUST STATE YOUR NAME
YOUR AFFILIATION ADD WHAT THE
USE OF. AN INNER OPPOSITION TO
THIS BILL PLEASE PROCEED OUT-
MODERATOR. WE HAVE NO
ADDITIONAL PAYMENTS AT THIS
TIME. OKAY WITH THAT THAT'S
GREAT SO- WHAT WE WANT TO DO IS
BRING THIS BACK TO OUR MEMBERS
AND I'M GONNA GO TO VICE CHAIR-
NIELSEN CENTER NIELSEN. THE
FIRST TERM AND REMEMBERS. I
CAN'T SUPPORT THIS LEGISLATION.
YOU KNOW CALIFORNIA ALREADY HAS
THE WORST REPUTATION I THINK IN
THE WORLD AS FAR AS BEING
HOSTILE TO BUSINESS. OVER THE
DECADES I'VE WATCHED OUR
POLICIES. IN THE FOREST IN THE
WILD LANDS OF CALIFORNIA. SEOUL.
PROTEK IF YOU WILL BY SOME
PEOPLE'S DEFINITION THE LAND
THAT WE HAVE NOW. PUT OURSELVES
IN THIS SITUATION IS
CATACLYSMIC FIRES OF THE FUEL
BUILD UP OVER YEARS OF OVER
AND- FRESHLY REGULATION BY
MULTIPLE AGENCIES IN THE STATE
AND FEDERAL GOVERNMENT. THIS
LEGISLATION IS ISRAELI THE- AN
IRRITANT ALLIES IN THE NEAR
TERM. INTERFERING IN THE
MARKETS THIS WAY WITH SWEEPING
DEFINITIONS OF RISK. I USUALLY
DON'T HAVE TO SPEAK ABOUT THESE
THINGS WITH THE PASSION THAT I
THAT I DO BUT THIS ONE IS JUST
GOING TOO FAR. IF ANYTHING
WE'RE TRYING TO MAKE A COMEBACK
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA NOW.
TO MANAGE OUR FORESTS AND
WILDLANDS AND HERE WE ARE GOING
TO. BE MICRO MANAGED IN THE
MARKETS AND THE BUREAUCRATIC
NIGHTMARE IN THE AMOUNT OF
FILINGS THAT WOULD HAVE TO BE
PLACED ON THE BURDENS ON THESE
BUSINESSES. AND MOST
PARTICULARLY LADIES AND
GENTLEMAN THE LITIGATION THAT
WILL A POLE AND INTO. FROM THE
PASSAGE OF THIS LEGISLATION.
OUR ORIGINAL. SEVERAL BOARD
JUST. THANK YOU CHAIR- I THINK
IT'S CLEAR THAT- CANADA-%
BROUGHT TO BEAR SOME IMPORTANT
POINTS- THAT ALLOW FOR
AMENDMENTS THAT WOULD OTHERWISE
EXCLUDE THEM- MAYBE I CAN POSE
A QUESTION TO THE AUTHORS TO
THE CHAIR. BY ALL MEANS. SO
WHEN WE START TALKING ABOUT-
FORCE AT RISK- THE PERSON COMES
MY WOULD BE LIKE BRAZIL. IS
THAT WHERE THIS IS. LARGELY
ORIENTED DETAILS OF THE
PROTECTION OF THE CHURCH IN
SEVENTY ONE OF SEVERAL
COUNTRIES AT THAT TIME TROPICAL
FORESTS THAT ARE CURRENTLY-
HAVING SOME LARGE AMOUNTS OF
ISSUES REGARDING SUSTAINABILITY
AND DEFORESTATION NOT JUST
BECAUSE OF THE- THERE A QUITE A
FEW OTHER COUNTRIES ALONG THE
TALK ABOUT. ALL RIGHT SO I
GUESS MY QUESTION- AS A FOLLOW
UP WOULD BE. WHEN WE START
DELVING INTO INTERNATIONAL
TRADE AND- PROMOTING CALIFORNIA
IS HAVING A DIFFERENT SET OF
STANDARDS. ONE OF THE CONCERNS
THAT I WOULD HAVE AND MAYBE YOU
CAN ANSWER IF IT'S BEEN
DEVELOPED AT ALL OR MAYBE IT'S
NOT AN ISSUE. ALTOGETHER IS
WHETHER OR NOT ANY TRADE
AGREEMENT. THAT MIGHT EXIST
BETWEEN THE US AND BRAZIL.
WOULD BE IN CONFLICT WITH.
PIECE OF DOMESTIC LEGISLATION
LIKE THIS THIS HERBAL BUSINESS
LEGISLATION IS NOT TARGET ANY
INDIVIDUAL COUNTRY WHAT IT DOES
IS SETS VALUES FOR US AS A
STATE AS TO WHETHER WE'RE GOING
TO CONTRIBUTE TO DEFORESTATION
FOR PROCUREMENT POLICIES IT'S
ONLY REGARDING STATE PURCHASING
INSIDE TELLING PRIVATE SECTOR
WHAT THEY CAN AND CANNOT DO.
AND WE HAVE PLENTY OF PRECEDENT
FOR INCLUDING LAST COUPLE
YEARS- BANNING COSMETICS THAT-
INVOLVE ANIMAL TESTING- THERE
WAS AT THE IME- THERE IS SOME
CONCERN FROM CHINA AT THE TIME
OF THE CONSOLE OTHER COUNTRIES
BUT NOT ONLY WAS IT A DOCTOR
BUT WE SEE THE INDUSTRY MOVE IN
A MUCH MORE POSITIVE DIRECTION
AGAIN IT'S NOT IT'S USING OUR
PURCHASING POWER TO REPRESENT
OUR VALUES AND IN NO WAY.
PROHIBITS ANY INTERACTION OR
TRADE WITH ANY NATION AS LONG
AS THEY'RE OPERATING IN A
SUSTAINABLE. MANNER AND THERE
ARE METRICS WITHOUT. ALL RIGHT
SIR THEY'RE IN A YOUR
ESTIMATION THERE NO CALL. WITH
THIS. PROCUREMENT POLICY IN
ANY. INTERNATIONAL AGREEMENT
THAT WE HAVE BETWEEN THE U. S.
OR ANY OF THE- RAIN FOREST- AND
PROTECTED. WOULD PRODUCING
AREAS OF THE WORLD. NO I FIND
IT IN PARALLEL TO OURS FOR FREE
COULD CONDUCT WHICH BANS.
PROCUREMENT OF FURNITURE OUT
LABOR. OKAY I THINK WE ARE
LOOKING AT THE HOLE IN THE
PAPER PRODUCTS AND STUFF LIKE
THAT- THIS MAY SEEM MORE
SYMBOLIC BUT I THINK THERE IS
ACTUAL- FINANCIAL CONSEQUENCE.
TO THIS- AND- I THINK BECAUSE
OF THAT I WOULD BE. I HAVE
CONCERNS THAT WE MAY BE
EMBARKING- ONCE AGAIN INTO
DISTURBING INTERNATIONAL TRADE
AND OUR INFLUENCE IN ALL AREAS
OF- FOREIGN POLICY- I THINK IF
THERE WAS- IF THERE WAS MORE.
MORE INVESTMENT IN RESEARCHING
THIS I WOULD FEEL MORE BETTER
ABOUT IT BUT AS IT STANDS RIGHT
NOW I THINK REPRESENTING THAT
THIS IS THE ONLY STATE
PROCUREMENT AND NOT PRIVATE
PROCUREMENT. THAT'S A
DIFFERENCE WITHOUT A
DISTINCTION- CELL THANK YOU. A
MEMBERS WISHING TO- DISCUSS
THIS ITEM. WE HAVE A MOTION.
CENTRE ALAN MOVES- A BEAT FOR
SIXTEEN- SEND A SEVEN MEMBER
CALLER WHICH LIKE CLOSER THANK
YOU MR CHAIR AND I'LL JUST SAY
OH CANADA. PUTTING FINAL BORN I
APPRECIATE THE OVER THE WORLD
TO THE CANADIAN GOVERNMENT AND
SUSTAINABILITY AND- INTERACTION
WITH THIS PIECE OF LEGISLATION
HOPE WE CAN CONTINUE TO WORK.
ON THOSE ISSUES AND I HOPE-
INVITED NEXT YEAR'S- CANDIDATES
CELEBRATION AND I'LL JUST AY
OTHER THAN THAT WHEN IT IS
APPLIES TO WHAT WE'RE SEEING
AROUND OUR STATE OUR COUNTRY
AND OUR WORLD OUR WORLD IS ON
FIRE AND IF IT DOES HAVE TO DO
WITH THE WAY THAT WE RESPOND
AND WE ACTUALLY PURCHASE- WE
HAVE AN ENORMOUS IMPACT GIVEN
THE SIZE OF OUR ECONOMY. AND
THE IFLUENCE OF OUR STATE. AND
THE INFLUENCE OF SO MANY OF YOU
CARRY WITH YOU WITH YOUR VOTE
AND YOUR SUPPORT SO WITH THAT
PERSPECTIVE OF ASPIRIN I
THOUGHT THANK YOU SEMI MEMBER
CALL RIGHT- THE BILL'S BEEN
MOVED BY SENATOR ALLEN THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
DOT BY DOT. HI NELSON. S. N. O.
YES AND NO ALAN RIGHT ALAN HI
ARCHER. PARTIAL I'D BACK. RIGHT
BETTER HI GORGEOUS. BORDERS NO
BRADFORD BRADFORD I LASER ON
LASER HI WHAT'S SO. JONES NO
JON SNOW CATALOGUER MELINDA'S
MELENDEZ NO PUT INTO NOW HI
TWENTY NO HI RUBIO WELL. WELL
SORRY RUBIO RUBIO I BILL AS-
EIGHT VOTES- FOR KNOWS- PUT
THAT BILL A CALL. OKAY MEMBERS
I THANK YOU SEVEN MEMBER. I
WILL NOW OPEN UP THE ROLE ON
EVERY BILL WE WILL DO THIS- I
THINK IT'S THE SCRIPT SAYS ONLY
ONCE BUT BECAUSE- WE HAVE A
SENATOR THAT'S A- YEP PUTTING A
BILL BEFORE THE SSME COMMITTEE
WILL WAIT FOR HER SO WE GIVE
THE KIDS SECULAR SECTOR PLEASE
OPEN THE ROLE ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR. THIS IS. THIS IS ON A
CONTENT CALENDAR ABSENT MEMBERS
ALAN. HI ALAN HI BECKER. HI
BAKER FIVE BRADFORD BRADFORD HI
WHAT'S SO WHAT'S SO HI RUBIO.
HI THAT'S THAT EVERYBODY. DO
YOU GO ABOUT. OKAY BUT THAT'S
THE AND IF YOU WILL- PUT THAT
ON THE ROLE. ALAMOUDI FILE ITEM
NUMBER ONE EIGHTY ONE ONE EIGHT
SECTOR PLEASE OPEN THE ROLE.
THIS IS FOLLOWED HIM ONE EIGHTY
ONE EIGHTY EIGHT ARE. ARE
ABSENT MEMBERS NELSON. ALAN
ALLEN HI BECKER. BECKER FIVE
BRADFORD BRADFORD HI WESSEL
WETZEL HI MELENDEZ. RUBIO RUBIO
HI. NO SEVEN NO. THE BILL STILL
ON CALL. SO MOVE THE FILE ITEM
NUMBER. SEVEN EIGHTY SIX FIVE
SEVEN. SECRETARY PLEASE OPEN
THE ROLE THIS IS FOLLOWING HIM
SEVEN EIGHTY SIX FIVE SEVEN
SHARE VOTING I ADVISED HER
VOTING NO. ABSENT MEMBERS ALAN.
BACKER BRADFORD. HI BRADFORD HI
WHAT'S SO. CATALOGUER WELL.
YEAH WELCOME NO. BILLS ALSO ON
CALL. THE FOLLOWING NUMBER
EIGHT EIGHTY TEN SEVENTY
SECRETARY PLEASE OPEN THE ROLE
AS A FOLLOW N EIGHT EIGHTY TEN
SEVENTY ABSENT MEMBERS ALAN.
ALLEN HI BECKER. BY BECKER HI
BRADFORD. BRAUGHER EYEING
WESSEL WHAT'S SO I CAN LONGER.
WILKE WELCOME HI THAT'S
FOURTEEN THE WRONG CALL
FOURTEEN ZERO THE BILLS ON CALL.
NOW MOVE TO FOLLOW THEM NUMBER
NINE AB ELEVEN SEVENTY THREE
SECRETARY PLEASE OPEN THE ROLE
THIS IS A FILE I'M NINE EIGHT
ELEVEN SEVENTY THREE ABSENT
MEMBERS SPECTER. HI SPECTER HI
BRADFORD ON BRADFORD HI WES SO
I WEAR SO HI JONES I. JONES HI
JONES HI KEN LONGER WELL HI
WELL I THAT'S FOURTEEN ZERO ON
COM FOURTEEN ZERO THE BOOK
DEALS ON CALL. YEAH I MOVED TO
FILE. I DON'T NUMBER FOURTEEN
HE B. ELEVEN OH THREE SECRETARY
PLEASE OPEN THE ROLE FILE I'M
FOURTEEN A. B. ELEVEN OH THREE
ABSENT MEMBERS PROFFERED. ARE
ROUGHER ALL RIGHT WHAT'S SO. HI
WHERE SITE JONES I DON'T I CAN
LONGER WELL RIGHT BOOK HI
FORTUNES ARE ON CALL FOURTEEN
ZERO ONE CALL NOW MOVED FILE
ITEM NUMBER FIFTEEN EIGHTY
ELEVEN TEN SECRETARY PLEASE
OPEN THE ROLE. L. R. FILE ITEM
OUT OF FIFTEEN AB ELEVEN TEN
ABSENT MEMBERS BRADFORD.
BRADFORD HI WESO HI WEST SO ALL
RIGHT JONES. JONES HI KEN
LONGER. MELENDEZ WELL ALL RIGHT
WELCOME BYE THAT'S THIRTEEN
ZERO ON CALL THIRTEEN ZERO ON
CALL. DOWNLOAD FILE NUMBER
EIGHTEEN AB FORTY SEVEN ONE
SECRETARY PLEASE OPEN THE ROLE
THIS IS FOLLOWED IN EIGHTEEN
EIGHTY FOURTEEN SEVENTY ONE
ABSENT MEMBERS BACKER. BORDERS
BORDERS I'D BRADFORD BRADFORD
HI JONES JONES HI KEN LONGER-
HAS THIRTEEN ZERO ON CALL
THIRTEEN ZERO BILLS ON A CALL
NOW MOVED T FOLLOW THE NUMBER
TWENTY TWO EIGHTY FOUR SIXTEEN
SECTOR PLEASE OPEN THE ROLE IS
THE FOLLOWING TWENTY TWO EIGHTY
FOUR SIXTEEN ABSENT MEMBERS.
WERE SO. CATALOGUER WELL. WEST
SO I. WELCOME HI THAT'S TEN TO
FOUR ON CALL TEN FOUR. FILLS
OUR CALL. NO ONE. IT IS A
MODERN- WE. THIS COMMITTEE WILL
BE IN RECESS UNTIL CENTER COM
LONGER- RETURNS FROM OUR
COMMITTEE.
MR SECRETARY CAN WE
OPEN UP THE ROLE YES HI THIS IS
FILE ITEM ONE AB ONE EIGHTEEN
ABSENT MEMBERS MELENDEZ.
THIRTEEN ONE OUT. THIRTEEN ONE
THAT MOTION PASSES AT ME THAT
BILL PASSES THIS IS FILE ITEM
SEVEN EIGHTY SIX FIVE SEVEN
SHARE BOARDING HI VICE
REPORTING NO ABSENT MEMBERS
ALAN BECKER WEST SO CAN LONGER
I CAN ORDER I. WELCOME. THAT
BILL AS SIX VOTES FOR SIX VOTES
AGAINST THAT MOTION FAILS- THE
THAT BILL WOULD BE GRANTED
RECONSIDERATION. FILE I'M AT
TEN SEVENTY ABSENT MEMBERS COME
LONGER I'VE COME OVER BY
FIFTEEN ZERO LEVELS OUT FIFTEEN
ZERO THAT BILL IS OUT. FILE
ITEM NINE A. B. ELEVEN SEVENTY
THREE ABSENT MEMBERS CAN LONGER.
HI KEN LONGER BY FIFTEEN ZERO
CHAIRMAN OF ELIZABETH KEANE
ZERO THAT BILLS OUT. FIVE ITEM
FOURTEEN A. B. ELEVEN OH THREE
ABSENT MEMBERS CAN LONGER I
HAVE COME OVER HI FIFTEEN ZERO
LEVELS ON. THE BILLS OUT WHAT
WAS THE. FIFTEEN TWO ZERO
FIFTEEN ZERO. FIRELIGHT I'M
FIFTEEN AB ELEVEN TEN ABSENT
MEMBERS COME LONGER I CAN LIKE
OR I HAVE AN S. FOURTEEN ZERO
FOURTEEN ZERO THAT BILLS OUT.
FIRE ALARM EIGHTEEN AB FOURTEEN
SEVENTY ONE ABSENT MEMBERS
BACKER CAN LONGER I CAN ORDER
HI FOURTEEN ZERO FOURTEEN ZERO
THAT BILL IS OUT. FIRELIGHT AND
TWENTY TWO EIGHTY FOUR SIXTEEN
ABSENT MEMBERS CAN LONGER HI
KAMMERER I ELEVEN TWO FOUR
ELEVEN FOR THAT BILL IS OUT.
AND THAT'S A LOT. THAT
CONCLUDES THE BUSINESS BEFORE
THE GOVERNMENTAL ORGANIZATIONS-
COMMITTED TODAY- MODERATOR IF
YOU'RE ON THAT WAS A JOB WELL
DONE THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
THOSE THAT WERE HEARD TODAY
YOUR COMMENTS OR SUGGESTIONS
PLEASE SEND THEM IN WRITING TO
OUR COMMITTEE OR VISIT OUR
WEBSITE YOUR COMMENTS JUST
SUGGESTIONS ARE IMPORTANT TO US
AND WE WANT TO INCLUDE YOUR
TESTIMONY IN THE VISUAL HEARING
RECORDS THANK YOU WE APPRECIATE
YOUR PARTICIPATION THANKS TO
EVERYONE FOR YOUR PATIENCE AND
COOPERATION WE HAVE CONCLUDED
THE AGENDA THE SENATE COMMITTEE
ON GOVERNMENTAL ORGANIZATION.
IS ADJOURNED.